l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement et la première d'entre elle va
être posée par Monsieur le Président Mattei pour
le groupe [Applaudissements] démocrate merci
madame la présidente madame la Première ministre
ces derniers jours nombre d'entre nous avons vu
avec inquiétude se multiplier sur les réseaux
sociaux les tags antisémites partout en France
cela nous rappelle avec horreur les temps de
la peur que nous croyons disparu cette peur est
ressentie aujourd'hui par nombre de familles
de confessions juives avec la multiplication
des actes antisémites depuis le 7 octobre
dernier pour l'année 2015 nous déplorions
808 actes antisémites au cours de ces trois
dernières semaines ces 850 actes ont été qui
ont été commis en France plus de 6000 messages
sur les réseaux sociaux ont fait l'objet d'un
signalement sur Faros en réponse 430 personnes
ont été interpellées 234 enquêtes ont été
ouvertes la réponse de l'État est forte et nous
la saluons mais au-delà la réponse pénale nous
députés démocrates sommes alarmés sur ce que
cette recrudescence de l'antisémitisme dit de
notre société car l'antisémitisme agit comme un
canari dans la mine l'arabin Delphine orvilleer
nous le rappelle la frénésie antisémite
révèle les failles de notre nation dans
l'esprit malade des antisémites les Français de
confession juifes sont et ne seront jamais des
que des juifs et non des citoyens ce faisant la
passion antisémite s'attaque au fondement même
de notre nation l'antisémitisme est une insulte
à notre histoire à nos principes républicains
à la cohésion nationale sans prendre un juif
c'est offenser la République c'est attaquer la
France de la même façon tout acte qui vise à
condamner l'autre à l'agresser pour ce qu'il est
pour sa religion pour son origine est
insupportable pour notre pays madame la
Première ministre face à ce fléo quelle réponse
pouvons-nous apporter non pas en tant qu'État
mais comme nation je vous remercie merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président la parole est à madame la
Première ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le président Jean-Paul matthi des slogans
aineux sur des banderoles des commentaires
odieux sur les réseaux sociaux des menaces des
insultes et parfois des coups l'antisémitisme à
de multiples visages tous aussi insupportables
depuis les attaques terroristes du 7 octobre
contre Israël les manifestations de haine se
sont intensifié plus de 850 incidents ont eu
lieu et près de 6000 signalements en ligne ont
été réalisés ces derniers jours à saint-toin
à Paris au petitquevilli les habitants ont
découvert des T des tags antisémites sur les
murs de leur ville des étoiles de David ou des
des croix gamés comme une évocation glaçante du
passé au nom du gouvernement je condamne
avec une fermeté absolue ces agissements
ignobles
l'antisémitisme c'est la lâcheté la haine de
l'autre et tous ceux qui se rendent coupables de
ces actes doivent être interpellés et condamnés
la France s'est construite depuis plus de 200
ans comme une terre de liberté d'ouverture et de
tolérance s'ans prendre à quelqu'un parce qu'il
est juif c'est s'en prendre à nos valeurs les plus
fortes c'est s'en prendre à ce qui nous rassemble
c'est s'en prendre à la même de la République rien
ne peut être toléré justifié ou excusé depuis le 7
octobre nous avons redoublé d'efforts le ministre
de l'Intérieur a immédiatement passé des consignes
de vigilance au préfet et aux forces de l'ordre
la sécurisation des lieux sensibles les écoles
les lieux de culte a été renforcé les enquêtes
avance et la justice est ferme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président mat d'ors et déjà plus de
430 interpellations et plus de 230 enquêtes en
cours nous ne laisserons rien passer depuis ce 7
octobre les Juifs de France connaissent le poids
de l'angoisse alors je veux leur dire avec mon
gouvernement et je n'en doute pas avec vous nous
sommes à vos côtés nous nous le resterons rien ne
justifie la haine et la violence c'est notre c'est
le devoir de notre pays de le combattre c'est
le devoir de la République de protéger tous les
Juifs de France et vous pouvez compter sur mon
engagement sans faille je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la Première ministre la parole
est à Madame Sandrine Rousseau pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères Catherine Colona madame la ministre
la France en tant que état tiersre au conflit
israélo-palestinien doit avoir une position claire
elle renoué avec son rôle historique consistant à
défendre le droit international tout le droit
international rien que le droit international
celui-ci exige la libération sans condition de
tous les otages civil la protection de toutes
les personnes civiles la mise en place en urgence
d'un corridor humanitaire permettant d'acheminer
les produits de première nécessité dont les
médicaments la levée complète du blocus de la
Bande de Gaza l'accès de la presse pour informer
sans entrave et témoigner de ce qui se passe
là-bas en ce sens lors de l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies réunies vendredi dernier la France a
voté une résolution largement adopté demandant une
trêve humanitaire immédiate durable et soutenue
menant à la cessation des activités des hostilités
pardon la communauté internationale et la France
mon sil vous plî RC depis plusieurs années à fa
appliquer le droit international laissant ainsi
la région se gangraer le cycle de la violence
s'amplifier nous devons agir en responsabilité
madame la ministre alors que l'armée israélienne
attaque en ce moment même Gaza par voie terrestre
tuant la population civile 3195 enfants morts et
mettant en danger les otages détenu par le Hamas
quelles sont les pressions que la France
envisage enfin de afin de mettre un TER
à cet enfer pouvez-vous madame la ministre
affirmer aujourd'hui devant l'Assemblée
nationale que la France appelle à
l'instar d'Antonio gterz cess le feu
humanitaire je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Laurence B secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'Europe merci madame la Présidente
d'abord je vous prexcuser ministre
Europe et des Affaires étrangères kenrine Colona
qui participe à Turin au comité de coopération
transfrontalière du Traité du kirinal madame la
députée c'estandrine Rousseau vous avez dit que
la France doit agir en responsabilité et vous
avez raison c'est précisément ce que fait notre
diplomatie c'est d'abord en responsabilité que la
France agit au plan politique vous l'avez rappelé
la France a voté en faveur du texte jordanien
présenté à l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
texte qui appelait à la mise en place d'une trêve
humanitaire menant à l'association des hostilités
c'est la position de la France depuis les premiers
jours de ce conflit c'est aussi la position
commune des Européens exprimés la semaine dernière
c'est un responsabilité également que la France
agit dans le domaine humanitaire au 20 millions
d'euros débloqués pour les agences internationales
et les ONG s'ajoute notre frais humanitaire au
bénéfice du Croissant Rouge égyptien et le soutien
que nous allons apporter à l'hôpital jordanien
de Gaza c'est un impératif et l'aide doit être
acheminée en quantité suffisante et de manière
durable c'est en responsabilité également que nous
cherchons avec nos partenaires dans la région
et au-delà un chemin qui évite un embrasement
régional et permette de tracer une perspective de
paix le déplacement du président de la République
les deux tournées de Catherine Colona dans
la région notre notre action au Conseil de
sécurité en vue de l'adoption d'une résolution ont
aussi cet objectif c'est enfit en responsabilité
que nous rappelons des principes simples la
condamnation du terrorisme du Hamas et des
crimes abjects qu'il a commis le droit d'Israël
à la sécurité et son devoir d'agir dans le cadre
du droit international et enfin évidemment
l'impérieuse nécessité d'un horizon politique
pour que les Palestiniens et les Israéliens puisse
vivre dans deux états côte à côte et en paix je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la ministre
je vais en profiter pour saluer la présence dans
l'hémicycle de famille et pour leur dire que nous
sommes à leur côté depuis l'attaque terroriste du
7 octobre dernier nous déplorons la mort de
35 de nos compatriotes cela fait aujourd'hui
25 jours que ne français sont tenu en otage
leurs familles sont donc présentes et je vous
remercie au nom de la représentation nationale de
leur dire collectivement que nous sommes à leur
côté
[Applaudissements]
et je ne doute pas que le gouvernement
fera tout ce qui est dans son possible
pour obtenir la libération de vos proches
le plus rapidement possible merci à tous
la parole est à Monsieur
Paul mollac pour le groupe
lot merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Agriculture
monsieur le ministre le groupe lot se félicite
du maintien des prix agricoles qui remunè mieux
nos agriculteurs toutefois certains problèmes
demeurent je veux tout d'abord évoquer les
retards de paiement de la pack qui touche
certains agriculteurs près de 500 dossiers
concernés dans le Gers autre sujet la crainte de
certaines filières face aux importations de pays
tiers tels que l'Australie je souhaite également
évoquer les difficultés de nos agriculteurs qui
se sont engagés dans la transition écologique
les bios en premier lieu qui souffrent d'une
contraction du marché et de la nécessité de faire
appliquer la loi sur la restauration collective
mais le cœur de ma question concerne ici les
mesures dites agro-environnemental et climatique
plus communément dénommé Maek elles sont un
outil majeur de la transition agroécologique
elles incitent au changement des pratiques et de
systèmes en rémunérant les surcts et les prises
de risque nous sommes 35 parlementaires bretons à
l'initiative de notre collègue Claudia rou à vous
avoir interpellé aujourd'hui les financements
de l'État sont largement insuffisants pour
honorer ces contrats selon région de France il
manquera entre 250 et 300 millions d'euros vous
comprendrez aisément que le fait d'abandonner des
exploitants agricoles pourtant engagés dans des
mesures d'adaptation agroécologique alors que l'on
veut baisser la consommation de produits phyau de
50% comporte quelques contradictions au moment
où nous sommes justement en train d'examiner
les crédits de la mission agriculture le monde
agricole qui agit en faveur de la transition
écologique vous écoute monsieur le ministre
l'état sera-t-il au rendez-vous pour aider les
agriculteurs vertueux je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Marc fen ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Paul mollac d'abord
répondre sur la question des paiements de la
PAC nous sommes dans une nouvelle période de
programmation vous vous souvenez sans doute
de ce qui s'était passé en 2015 quand nous
étions trouvé face à une très grande impasse
je vois que vous vous en souvenez parfaitement
nous sommes dans la disposition d'avoir pu payer
dès le le 16 octobre ça veut pas dire qu'il y a
pas un certain nombre de sujets de dossier dans
un certain nombre de département mais nous sommes
à un tau de près de 90 % de dosser payés à la date
où je vous parle ne faisons pas des exceptions qui
sont des ennuis pour nous aussi hein des règles
général je crois qu'on peut aussi se féliciter il
faut saluer les services des chambes d'agriculture
les syndicalismes globalement et les services
de l'État qui sont au rendez-vous du paiement
d'une pack qui n'est pas la même que celle que
nous connaissions dans la période complémentaire
deuxième élément vous dire sur la question de la
transition écologiques et les grandes transitions
il y a plusieurs dispositifs dans la pack il
y a la conversion à l'agriculture biologique
il y a les dispositifs de l'écorégime et il y a
les mesures agrienvironnemental que vous citez
oui nous avons une difficulté en particulier sur
la Bretagne d'abord vous rappelez que l'enveloppe
qui est celle des MAEC est la même elle est même
en légère augmentation que dans la précédente
programmation donc l'état est au rendez-vous la
différence c'est qu'elles étaient gérées par les
régions désormais elles sont gérées par l'État
mais ce n'est pas ça le sujet le sujet que nous
avons désormais c'est un sujet d'enveloppe qui
en particulier en Bretagne dépasse les enveloppes
qui avaient été prédéfinies y compris avec les
régions je rappelle que ça n'est pas une logique
de guichet c'est une logique dans une enveloppe
de sélection de mesures agréenvironnementales
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse dans le
temps qui nous est imparti puisqu'on est dans
la période de préprogrammation c'est de faire en
sorte qu'on regarde si tous les financements qui
devaient être mobilisés je pense en particulier
au financement des agences de l'eau qui doivent
mettre 70 millions d'euros supplémentaires
par an sur ces mesures environnementales
agrienvironnemental bien au rendez-vous pour qu'on
puisse couvrir les besoins donc on regarde dans ce
cadre là pour faire en sorte vous avez raison sur
ce sujet là comme sur d'autres qu'on soit bien au
rendez-vous des attentes des agriculteurs en
tout cas vous pouvez compter sur moi pour le
faire et pour sur le gouvernement comme on
le fait depuis le début sur ces sujets je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame constance legrip pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
la bête immonde existe toujours la bête immonde
de l'antisémitisme et elle exhale à nouveau un
souffle noséabon et ignoble la haine des Juifs
cette haine des Juifs peut sembler prendre des
habits neufs des foné et l'antisionisme en
é un de fauné de plus en plus répandu dans
les rues de notre pays sur les réseaux sociaux
dans les universités peut-être même au sein de
partis politiques représentés dans cet hémicycle
mais c'est toujours la même haine alimentée main
par l'islamisme la haine d'Israël et le
complottisme depuis le 7 octobre ce sont
840 actes antisémites qui ont été recensé
dans notre pays 430 personnes interpellées
840 actes antisémites en 3 semaines soit beaucoup
beaucoup plus que durant l'année écoulée c'est une
véritable flambée de l'antisémitisme à laquelle
nous assistons dans notre pays insulte injure
menace de mort tag dégradation de bâtiment
agression physique tentative d'incendie contre
des portes d'appartements cyber harcèlement rythme
le quotidien de beaucoup trop de NS compatriotes
de confessions juifes qui se sentent menacés
et qui ont peur cet antisémitisme grandissant
désinhibé dans la France d'aujourd'hui il fait
peur il nous fait peur il nous fait honte le
combattre doit être l'affaire de tous de tous
les républicains pas seulement l'affaire de
nos compatriotes Juifs c'est notre affaire à nous
tous car cet antisémitisme ce n'est pas la France
c'est la négation de la République française
c'est une attaque contre notre République et
nos valeurs monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous dire
à la représentation nationale à tous les Français
quelles sont les mesures précises que vous avez
mis en place pour protéger les Français juifs tous
les Juifs en France protéger leur sécurité et nous
dire également quelles sont les mesures envisagées
pour renforcer la mobilisation notre mobilisation
à tous contre ce poison de l'antisémitisme
merci beaucoup ma cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald daranin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outremèes merci madame la présidente madame
la députée constancerip comme l'a dit madame la
Première ministre le président de la République
nous a demandé dès évidemment les drames
ignobles des attentats terroristes islamistes
contre les populations israéliennes dès le 7
octobre de renforcer considérablement la sécurité
de tous les lieux où les Français de confession
juives vont pour leur culte vont évidemment mettre
leurs enfants à l'école s'ils le souhaitent ou
dans les lieux culturels ou communautaires
qui fréquentent assidument c'est donc
950 sites partout en France sur le territoire
national que nous protégeons grâce aux 10000
policiers gendarmes et militaire de sentinelle
qui permettent en effet de lutter contre cette
peur qui touche légitimement nos compatriotes
de confession juives et dont la République est
là pour les protéger absolument complètement
et jour et nuit ces actes antisémite ces actes
antisémites madame la députée malheureusement
ne sont pas une légende 857 actes antisémite
depuis le 7 octobre c'est-à-dire autant d'actes
antisémite que depuis toute l'année écoulée en 3
semaines grâce à la position des des policiers des
gendarmes des militas de sentinell présents devant
les lieux communautaires que j'ai évoqué c'est
425 interpellés et je veux dire ici la fermeté
notamment du ministère de l'Intérieur pour le
retrait de titre systématique des étrangers
qui seraient parmi ces personnes interpellées et
l'éloignement systématique il y a 27 personnes
dans centre de rétention administratif depuis
une semaine du fait notamment des interpellations
fait par le ministère de de l'intérieur nous
avons également une haine sur sur Internet
5916 signalements Faros dont 296 personnes ont
été identifiées par les services du ministère
de la Justice et je vrais donner deux exemple
ici pour comprenne qu'il n'y ait pas d'impunité
un individu étranger a été renvoyé dans son
pays le 9 octobre dernier suite à des crit de
mort au Juifs mort à Israël un individu le 28
octobre sur TikTok qui a appelé à la haine et
à la menace de mort contre le rabat de Levalois
a non seulement été interpellé mis en garde à
vue et déféré par les services du ministère de
la Justice en prison merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel
Maquet pour le groupe les républicains merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la transition énergétique madame la ministre
vous nous avez présenté triomphalement je crois
la semaine dernière une réforme du marché
de l'électricité la position de la France
aurait prévalu sur celle de l'Allemagne une fois
n'est pas coutume il faut donc s'en réjouir cette
victoire c'est d'abord celle des républicains
qui réclament de longues dates avec constance
et parfois contre les bans de la majorité que les
prix de l'électricité soient moins dépendant de
ceux du gaz et que le parc nucléaire historique
soit soutenu dans les défis qui l'attendent
mieux vaut tard que jamais vous rattrapez les
dégâts du premier mandat présidentiel placé sous
l'idéologie antinucléaire mais les Français ont
appris à se méfier des effets d'annonce l'hiver
dernier leur a montré les limites du système
en cas de hausse des prix la répercussion sur
le pouvoir d'achat est immédiat en cas de baisse
par contre on doit attendre très longtemps pour
voir les factures diminuer pour cette pour que cet
accord soit vraiment bénéfique pour les français
pour les artisans pour les commerçants comme nos
boulangers dont la situation est si difficile et
notre compétitivité industrielle il faut un
engagement clair les contrats bidirectionnels
permettront à l'état de soutenir EDF lorsque les
prix sont bas et à EDF de reverser à l'état ce
surplu lorsque les prix seront hauts ma question
madame la ministre est donc très simple dans cette
hypothèse de pris élevé est-ce que ces recettes
seront immédiatement et intégralement reversées
au ménage aux artisans et aux industriels
concrètement est-ce que les Français bénéficieront
des prix bas qu'ils méritent au regard des
investissements massifs sur le nucléaire qu'ils
ont consentis depuis 50 ans enfin prévoyez-vous
pour nos petites et moyennes entreprises les
boulangers les restaurateurs les artisans qui sont
exclus des tarifs réglementés alors que certains
de nos pays partenaires européens protègent
leurs PME bravo je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier verrand ministre en charge
du renouveau démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement merci Madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Emmanuel Maquet c'est vrai qu'avec le président
de la République nous avions fait une promesse
au français celle de reprendre le contrôle des
prix de l'électricité celle de reprendre en main
l'avenir énergétique de la France je vous réponds
à la place d'agè perunach parce qu'elle est elle
est absente mais je le fais avec plaisir et vous
nous donnez vous nous donnez un point positif
monsieur le député et je vais me permettre de le
faire aussi à mon tour c'est vrai que nous avions
en commun cette conviction que c'est en européen
que nous gagnerions ce combat et n nous opposions
ainsi à l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
qui considérait que le marché européen rendait
absolument impossible cette solution européenne et
en faisait même un argument de plus souverainiste
pour sortir du marché européen et pour autant
la promesse du président de la République elle
a été tenue parce que nous avons obtenu de
nos voisins allemands et nous avons obtenu
de la Commission européenne cette capacité à
découpler le prix de l'électricité et du gaz
et donc cette capacité à reprendre effectivement
le contrôle des prix de l'électricité maintenant
que cet accord est en place on se tourne
vous le savez vers l'avenir avec la loi
de production énergétique c'est une loi qui
va marquer une étape clé dans la définition
de notre politique énergétique nationale elle
va nous permettre de nous projeter dans un mix
énergétique décarboné avec la reconnaissance
du nucléaire vous l'avez dit mais aussi des
émissions des gaz des des énergies renouvelables
mais aussi la sobriété énergétique il sera aussi
question de notre sécurité d'approvisionnement
mais également de la régulation après 2025 avec
l'objectif partagé là encore monsieur le député
décidément que les français bénéficient le plus
vite possible du prix le plus proche des coûts
de production donc les mécanismes sont sont en
cours de réflexion et d'élaboration et dans les
prochains jours nous mettrons à la consultation
la stratégie française énergie climat qui
reprendra d'ailleurs très largement les
travaux du député Armand que je salue ici mais
aussi de l'ensemble des groupes politiques de
notre Parlement qui travaillent depuis des mois
avec les élus locaux et qui servira de base à la
loi de production énergétique je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre 2 secondes
cet accord fera-t-il baisser oui ou non la
facture des Français je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Darville
pour le groupe GDR madame la ministre ce dimanche
sur le marché de port debouc des artistes
s'étaient donné rendez-vous afin de produire
une œuvre collective pour la paix à destination
de l'ONU l'aspiration à la paix est forte dans
notre peuple et parmi les peuples du monde et il
est salut l terire que cette aspiration matinée
d'inquiétude et de révolte puisse se manifester
dans un moment où l'humanité est traversée par
les conflits nous n'oublions pas l'Ukraine ou
l'Arménie la désolation les bombes la fuite
les morts les attaques criminelles meurtrières
et aveugles du Hamas ont alimenté un engrenage
de guerre et de violence qui semble sans limite
l'offensive militaire qui s'intensifie à Gaza
est insupportable tous les crimes de guerre
doivent être condamnés les Nations Unies
décrivent une situation où une population entière
est déshumanisée cela ressemble à une vengeance
aveugle à une terrible punition collective et le
risque d'un embrasement n'est pas écarté bien sûr
il faut une trêve humanitaire d'urgence et la
libération des otages mais en toile de fond il
y a ce conflit qui dure depuis des décennies et
qui ne se règlera pas ainsi il y a la persistance
de l'occupation et du blocus le développement
de la colonisation qui prive une part de l'hum
de ses droits élémentaires dans le fracas et le
drame ces événements viennent nous rappeler à
quel point nos organisations internationales
ont été affaiblis à force d'être contourné à
quel point le droit international est fragilisé
à force d'être bafoué les nationalismes et les
intégrismes se nourrissent du conflit
installent une polarisation mortifère
qui ferme les issues alimente les haines
or il ne peut y avoir de paix durable que
dans la justice et le respect du droit des
peuples il y a des interlocuteurs possibles
je pense à Marouan bargouti parce que nous n'avons
rien d'autre en tête que le sort de ces femmes et
de ces hommes d'Israël et de Palestine nous
souhaitons que la France par le haut cessz le
feu je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
la Ministre Laurence bon ministre chargé de
l'Europe mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Pierre d'ville je vais
vous faire une réponse en deux temps la la
première en ce qui concerne les crimes de
guerre que vous avez mentionné et la deuxième sur
les perspectives politiques et des deux états le
7 octobre dernier des milliers de terroristes du
Hamas épaulés par d'autres groupes terroristes
dont le Djihad islamique et la branche armée du
FPLP ont abattu en Israël plus de 1400 personnes
et vous avez vu comme moi les images vous avez vu
comme moi la sauvagerie la barbarie les giif tué
assassiné les femmes et les bébés mutilés les
corps sans vie profané parce que juif comme
l'a dit le président de la République cette
barbarie qui s'est abattu sur Israël est aussi
une catastrophe pour les Palestiniens que nous
n'associons en aucune manière au Hamas qui dirige
Gaza avec la terreur le terrorisme est un fléo
pour le Moyen-Orient il est aussi pour nous il
faut rappeler que 35 de nos compatriotes ont été
sauvagement assassinés par le hin et que ce groupe
terroriste détient en otage certainement plusieurs
autres de nos compatriotes dont nous sommes
toujours sans nouvelle donc nous le disons Israël
doit pouvoir se défendre et ce droit doit se faire
dans le cadre du droit international qui doit être
respecté toujours la France a été au côté du droit
elle est aujourd'hui maintenant au-delà de
l'urgence humanitaire c'est le deuxième temps de
ma réponse il faut mieux répondre aux aspirations
légitimes des Palestiniens les Palestiniens
veulent vivre dans la dignité loin des atrocités
des terroristes du Hamas il va pouvoir vivre en
paix avec les Israéliens et non pas face à face
mais côte à côte c'est effectivement de notre
responsabilité collective de redessiner un horizon
politique et même de répondre à cette aspiration
la position de la France est constante et nous
la réaffirmons aujourd'hui avec force il faut
de la sécurité pour Israël et un état pour les
palestinien ces deux éléments forment un tout
indissociable madame colonel a sans ambigé lors
du sommet de la paix je vous mercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Marie-Pierre
rixin pour le groupe Renaissance ma question
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre depuis le 24
juin 2022 l'avortement n'est plus un droit
fédéral aux États-Unis l'atteinte
à ce droit fondamental fragile sur
le plan juridique dans l'une des plus grandes
démocraties du monde confirme la réversibilité
des droits des femmes et l'impérieuse nécessité
de garantir constitutionnellement le droit à
l'IVG face aux assauts de force réactionnaire
c'est pourquoi dès le 30 juin 2022 la majorité
présidentielle déposa une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à garantir le droit à
d'IVG et que par la suite députés puis sénateurs
dans une démarche transpartisane ont adopté tour
à tour deux textes constitutionnels allant dans
ce sens aujourd'hui avec la mobilisation tion de
nombreux parlementaires et des associations
féministes le président de la République a
annoncé déposer au Conseil d'État un projet de
loi constitutionnel il ouvre ainsi la voix à un
processus de réforme constitutionnelle inédit
dans le monde afin de garantir pleinement la
liberté des femmes à pouvoir recourir à l'IVG
en France la vulnérabilité des droits des
femmes est une réalité implacable l'intérêt de la
constitutionnalisation de ce droit est donc double
à la fois lui conférer une plus grande sécurité
juridique et le rendre irréversible pour les
générations futures et d'autre part manifester
avec force l'attachement de la France à ce droit
fondamental des femmes à travers cette décision
pionnière le président de la République rappelle
combien ce droit loin d'être seulement un sujet
de femme est au cœur de notre vie démocratique
ici en France pays des Lumières pays des droits
de l'homme et assurément des droits des femmes
madame la Première ministre quand le droit à
sera-t-il pérénisé en France et inscrit dans
notre Constitution merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Marie-Pierre xxin il y a une chose que toutes
les femmes ne savent que trop bien leurs droits
sont fragiles et Simone de beauauvoir disait
vrai en affirmant qu'il seraiit toujours les
premiers remis en question au cœur de ces
droits il y a celui de disposer de son corps
il y a la garantie de pouvoir librement
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse ce droit est le fruit d'une
lutte du Manifeste des 343 du procès
de bobini ce droit est le fruit du courage
celui de Simon veille à la tribune de cette
assemblée
si ce droit est aujourd'hui défendu sur la
quasi-ttalité des bans de cet hémicycle nous
avons un devoir de vigilance vous l'avez
rappelé la décision de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis l'année dernière à rappelé que le droit
à l'avortement pouvait être menacé même dans une
grande démocratie et jusque sur notre continent
plusieurs partis d'extrême droite veulent
remettre en cause cette liberté fondamentale
pour les femmes ce devoir de vigilance vous
le partagez c'est le sens de la proposition de
loi constitutionnelle adoptée à une très large
majorité sur ces bancs et voté ensuite par le
Sénat ce devoir de vigilance nous le partageons le
8 mars dernier en rendant l'hommage de la Nation à
Giselle Alimi le président de la République s'est
engagé à inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans le marbre
de la Constitution et dimanche dernier après
concertation avec les groupes parlementaires le
président de la République a annoncé qu'un projet
de loi constitutionnel serait transmis dès cette
semaine au Conseil d'État et présenté au Conseil
des ministres avant la fin de l'année ce texte
permettra de consacrer plus encore la liberté
des femmes à recourir à l'IVG en l'inscrivant
dans la Constitution mesdames et messieurs les
députés certains affirment qu'il n'y a pas
urgence pour le droit des femmes je crois
au contraire qu'il y a toujours urgence à se
battre toujours urgence àve au liberté des
femmes c'est ma conviction c'est la conviction de
mon gouvernement et c'est c'est la vôtre et c'est
une conviction qui rassemble largement sur ces
bans c'est pourquoi pour toutes les femmes avec
le président de la République nous souhaitons que
ce ce droit soit inscrit dans la Constitution en
2024 je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre la parole est à Monsieur JP
insoumise madame la Première ministre la
directrice exécutive de l'UNICEF a affirmé
lundi devant le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU plus
de 420 enfants sont tués ou blessés chaque jour
à Gaza Jean-François Corti vice-président de
Médecin du Monde explique dans Libération on
est passé d'une prison à ciel ouvert à un charnier
à ciel ouvert madame la Première ministre vous et
votre gouvernement avez fait le choix de soutenir
inconditionnellement le gouvernement de Monsieur
netanah dans une démocratie c'est le droit pour
d'autres et ils sont nombreux de penser de dire
que le carnage doit s'arrêter tout de suite qu'il
faut in cesser le feu immédiat dans le monde
entier notamment en Europe comme à Londres très
récemment des manifestations très puissantes ont
lieu en France ces manifestations sont interdites
comme cela a été le cas samedi dernier à Paris
madame la Première ministre pourquoi pourquoi
cette position intenable et incompréhensible
réalité un climat dangereux est en train de
sinstaller dangereux pour le pays la démocratie
et l'ensemble des libertés publi rassemblement
national et dans votre majorité certains ont cru
bon de s'en prendre à la liberté de la presse
de cibler la FP et de se prononcer pour que
lui soit retiré ses subventions publiques un
autre député de votre majorité rajoutant menace
réelle don ce dernier est l'objet déclare à la
radio jeanluc Mélenchon est un danger pour la
société il devrait être fich la première ministre
vous désolidarisez-vous nettement de ces propos
irresponsables la première victime d'une guerre
est la vérité c'est vrai à chaque fois ça l' est
particulièrement à Gaza pilonné réduite au silence
à ce jour 28 journalistes y ont été tués deux
tribunes viennent d'être publié demandant aux
autorités françaises d'appeler à la protection
des journalistes qui tentent actuellement
de travailler dans l'enclave pour y faire
leur métier informé reprenez-vous cet appel à
votre compte autant de questions relié à cette
je vous remercie la par Monsieur
Habib s'il vous plaît vous n'avez
pas la parole la parole est à Madame
Laurence bon ministre des affaires
européennes merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le député Jérôme mesdames etessieurs les députés
je vais peut-être PE mais d'abord Israël dans
sa réponse légitime à l'attaque terroriste dont
elle a été victime doit aussi protéger les
populations civiles en application du droit
humanitaire car ces populations civiles n'ont pas
payer les prix des crimes commis par des groupes
terroristes qui ne les représentent pas il faut
être clair je crois que le gouvernement l'a été
les terroristes du Hamas ne représentent pas le
peuple palestinien la cause palestinenne il faut
le dire encore plus dans le contexte actuel de
grande volatilité où certains acteurs tentent
d'installer de la confusion le rejet le plus
ferme des actions du Hamas est le moyen le plus
sûr de faire entendre la voix des Palestiniens
et la France condamne les agissements du Hamas
et elle soutient les droits des Palestiniens
peut-être puis-je aussi rappeler que face à
la crise humanitaire qu'endure la population
civile une population civile qui souffre Gaza
puisque vous l'avez évoqué la France a annoncé 20
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui passeront par
les agences des Nations Unies le CICR et les
ONG et elle est prête à accroître cet effort
si nécessaire et cette aide aux population et aux
déplacés elle a demandé l'ouverture des corridors
et la pose humanitaire pour la leur faire parvenir
d'urgence à nouveau je le dis la distribution de
l'aide aux populations civile à commencé par
les vulnérables suppose une trêve humanitire
qui pourra amener à insisser le feu et les
personnes qui souhaitent pouvoir sortir de
Gaza doivent pouvoir le faire sans en être
empêché nous l'avons demandé pour nos agents
nos ressortissants leurs famille et enfin
il faudra une solution politique pour que
les deux peuples puis viv côte à côte je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre je vous remercie la parole est à madame
Béatrice sur PHPP Bard pour le rassemblement
national merci Madame la la présidente ma
question s'adresse à Madame Rima abdoumak
ministre de la Culture 3 semaines après
le début de la guerre entre Israël et le
mouvement palestinien hamass Gaza est coupé du
monde cette phrase est extraite d'une dépêche
AFP du 27 octobre on y liit bien la guerre
contre le mouvement palestinien àas bravo
en fait cette dépêche n'est que le reflet des
consignes donné par la direction de l'agence
dans une note interne on y lit notamment que
pour décrire le Hamas il faut parler je cite
de combattant du Hamas et non d'islamiste du
Hamas tandis que le qualificatif terroriste
est tout simplement à proscrire le directeur
de l'information expliquant que ce mot a tout
bonnement perdu son sens pourtant il n'y a pas
si longtemps laafp employait ce mot de terror
pour décrire les exactions de daesh d'alqaïda
les assassinats de Boko Haram l'attentat contre
Charlie Hebdo mais que s'est-il passé depuis
décapiter des bébés éventrer des femmes enceintes
brûler des êtres humains kidnappé violé ce n'est
pas du terrorisme et bien non apparemment pour
lafp lafp est l'une des trois grandes agences
mondiales la seule européenne ses abonnés
sont les médias français mais aussi étrangers
les entreprises les institutions son pouvoir
d'influence est donc énorme considérable j'ai
été journaliste près de 40 ans pendant de longues
années la FP c'était la Bible de l'information
mais ce temps-là est révolu alors madame la
ministre l'état s'apprête à verser 141 millions
d'euros à la FP budget en hausse de 5 % au titre
écoutez bien de sa mission d'intérêt général
alors madame la ministre comment comptez-vous
réagir quand sur le site de votre ministère
il est écrit que la FP et la seule agence
mondiale qui produise de l'information originale
complète objective et digne de confiance je vous
remci la parole est à Madame Rima Abdou malac
ministre de la Culture madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Ballard un premier appel pour paraphraser
ce que disait ma collègue Laurence boun la France
a très clairement défini le Hamas comme un groupe
terroriste ainsi que l'Union européenne et
un très grand nombre de pays autre rappel
important si le ministerère de la culture
fin mon je vais être obligé de vous rappeler
à [Applaudissements] l'ordre si le ministère
la culture finance en partie lafp lafp n'est
pas une agence gouvernementale c'est une agence
de presse indépendante et à l'instar des agences
Reuters ou Associated Press lafp a expliqué
que depuis plus de 20 ans ils ont pris cette
consigne de ne pas utiliser le mot terrorisme
pour s'en tenir au faits mais il me semble
que les faits décrits dans le cas des attaques
barbares du Hamas sont suffisamment claires pour
que tout le monde comprenne qu'il s'agit d'actes
terroristes les médias qui rédigent des articles
à partir des dépêches de lafp utilise d'ailleurs
très souvent s'il vous plaît on écouteot terrorist
dans le contexte de dans le contexte de gravité
est-ce que vous pouvez m'écouter jusqu'au bout'il
vous plaît dans le contexte de gravité que nous
vivons et je le dis avec d'autant plus d'émotion
en présence de famille d'otage retenu s'il vous
plaît depuis le 7 octobre où le Hamas a franchi
toutes les lignes rouges imaginables avec cette
barbarie et cette cruauté inqualifiable je peux
comprendre que le choix de ne pas utiliser ce
mot de terrorise pu susciter des remous des
incompréhensions des indignations mais monsieur
le député Ballard le gouvernement n'écrit pas les
dépêches de lafp et ne corrige pas les dépêches de
laafp la presse est indépendante dans notre pays
monsieur le député Balard ce qui m'a choqué pour
ma part puisque vous me demandez mon avis c'est la
mention de l'exemple de Nelson Mandela dans un des
communiqués d'explication de laafp je pense qu'on
ne peut pas laisser penser merci qu'on met sur le
même plan le Hamas et Nelson Mandela et j'aurais
aimé que l' fait mesure cette responsabilité
toute particulière merci beaucoup madame la
ministre bon allez s'il vous plaît un
peu de calme on essaie d'écouter les
différents orateurs et la parole est
à madame Béatrice bamie pour le groupe
horizon merci Madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre des Sports des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques madame la ministre
l'attaque du quart de l'Olympique Lyonnais ce
dimanche soir est le symbole d'un profond
abétissement et c'est un exemple désastreux
pour la jeunesse mais c'est plus que cela c'est
une insulte lancée à la face des sportifs de tous
ceux qui pratique qui aime et qui encadre le sport
en France c'est aussi pour eux pour ces millions
de Français que je vous adresse cette question car
le sport c'est avant tout de très belles histoires
des valeurs du lien social de l'émancipation le
dépassement de soi et le respect des règles tous
les jours et sur tous les terrains les 180000
clubs qui maillent notre territoire permettent
d'élever les corps et les esprits d'offrir un
cadre et des certitudes nous sommes nombreux à
être convaincus que le sport porte une partie des
remèdes au mots que connaît notre société et notre
jeunesse en particulier je salue les milliers
d'animateurs d'éducateurs et d'entraîneurs qui
uvrent sur tous les territoires de la République
nous leur sommes reconnaissant pour le travail
social qu'ils accomplissent la pratique du sport
sera la grande cause nationale pour 2024 dans cet
esprit le président de la République a annoncé
une nouvelle impulsion en faveur de l'inclusion
par le sport notamment par la création d'une
alliance pour copiloter cette politique publique
essentielle un acte fondateur a d'ors et déjà été
posé ce comité de l'Alliance a été confirmé au
cours du récent comité interministériel des
villes madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous
réaffirmer l'engagement du du gouvernement
à faire du sport un pilier majeur du pacte
républicain pouvez-vous nous préciser les éléments
concrets soutenant l'inclusion sur nos territoires
et dans les clubs sportifs je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Amélie ministre
sport des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
madame la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs
les Députés madame la députée Béatrice béami vous
mentionnez l'attaque AB dont on fait l'objet à
Marseille les bus de l'Olympique Lyonnais et je
ne veux pas oublier les gestes antisémites les
cris racistes et les champs homophobes qui
ont été par ailleurs à déplorer en tribune
dimanche soir je veux le redire avec la fermeté
que ces comportements appellent jamais nous
ne cèderons face à ceux qui cassent détruisent
ou salissent le sport les auteurs de ses faits
seront retrouvés poursuivis et condamnés avec
des sanctions que je souhaite les plus sévères
possibles leurs agissements sont la négation
même du sport et de ses valeurs vous l'avez dit
le sport a autre chose à apporter en particulier
à notre jeunesse parfois en perte de repèr pour
elle le sport a le pouvoir de redonner un cadre
et du sens c'est la raison pour laquelle sous
l'impulsion du Président de la République et de la
première ministre mon ministère porte en effet une
ambition et des moyens inédits pour l'inclusion
par le sport avec un nouvel investissement de 300
millions d'euros au côté des collectivités dans
les équipements sportifs notamment en qpv avec un
réseau constitué de 10000 clubs sportifs engagés
à travers les territoires partout en France avec
le recrutement de 1000 éducateurs sociosportifs
la mobilisation de 50 millions d'euros pour ces
missions d'animation d'intervention et
de médiation ces mesures elles seront
suivies animées par une nouvelle alliance pour
l'inclusion par le sport transpartisan composé
d'élus de servicees de l'état de représentants de
la société civile et d'acteurs associatifs dont
l'action nous permettra d'augmenter de 20 à 100000
le nombre de bénéficiaires des actions d'insertion
par le sport en capitalisant sur les dispositifs
mis en place depuis 2017 cette alliance elle va
nous permettre aussi de piloter l'été olympique
et paralympique que nous préparons avec les clubs
sportifs et avec les ministres de l'Éducation
nationale de la culture et de la ville pour que
l'élan des jeux bénéficie aussi à la jeunesse des
quartiers populaires à l'été 24 et que le sport
oui contribue à cimenter le pacte républicain
merci beaucoup madame la ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Gérard leol pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente madame la Présidente
cher collègue madame la Première ministre votre
gouvernement dont la plupart des membres sont
atteints d'une telle immodestie qu'il déclare
à longueur de discours qu'aucun gouvernement
n'a jamais fait mieux devrait au moins respecter
ses engagements en effet le temps semble loin où
vous vous engagiez madame la Première ministre
où vous promettiez de gouverner autrement dans
le dialogue et la coconstruction dans nos
débats parfois vifs parfois houleux parfois
consensuel de nombreux amendements ont été
adoptés pour corriger améliorer vos projets
de budget que vous menacez régulièrement par
le 493 c'est notamment le cas d'un amendement
important pour améliorer les dispositifs
d'accompagnement social des afeu c'est aussi
le cas de plusieurs amendements de rallonge budget
relatif à l'insertion par l'activité économique ou
encore à l'expérimentation territoire zéro chômeur
de longue durée créé en 2016 et mise en œuvre dès
2017 c'est une belle réussite nous le découvrons
dans nos territoires comme à l'entreprise à but
d'emploi la source à Port Jérôme sursène hélas le
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 ne prévoyait
que 69 millions d'euros contraignant l'association
à renoncer aux 25 nouvelles expérimentations
prévues en 2024 4 actuellement 58 territoires
l'ont mis en place et plus de 5000 personnes
ont retrouvé du travail grâce à cette association
cette expérimentation est même saluée à Bruxelles
qui souhaite mobiliser le Fond Européen
d'innovation sociale lors de la séance
dernière des questions gouvernement le ministre
du travail avait été interrogé sur ce sujet
avait répondu par de trop nombreuses contevérités
c'est pourquoi hier soir une réaction collective
de nombreux parlementaires de plusieurs groupes
politiques a permis en commission des finan de
voter deux amendements l'un à 31 millions d'euros
l'autre à 20 millions d'euros supplémentaires
écoute action résultat résumiez-vous en juillet
2022 allez-vous enfin écouter le Parlement et
retenir ses propositions bra merci beaucoup mon
cher collègu la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
dusopt ministre du Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député le
seul vous citez l'expérimentation territoire
zé chemur de longue durée comme vous l'avez
dit elle a été mise en place par une loi 2016
avec 10 territoires et le gouvernement succè
suivant avait porté cette expérimentation à
60 territoires nous sommes à 58 aujourd'hui vous
dites le gouvernement tient pas ses engagements
en 2017 c'était 15 millions d'euros qui étaient
budgetés dans le budget de l'État dont 5 ont été
consommés en 2023 cette année ce sont 44 44,9
million d'euros qui ont été inscrits et nous
finançons effectivement des expérimentations
dans à date 58 territoires qui ont été labelis
après que le comité de sélection les ait agréé
et que j'ai signé les arrêtés d'agrément nous
avons inscrit dans le budget 2024 69 millions
d'euros une augmentation de 53 %. vous conviendrez
monsieur le député que passer de 15 millions à
69 millions d'euros en l'espace de 6 ans n'est
pas tout à fait commun pour une expérimentation
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui nous en sommes à
une situation où il y a 58 territoires agréés et
l'association nous a fait savoir que de nouveaux
territoires pourrai être proposés j'ai dit à cette
association par l'intermédèire de mes équipes bien
év évidemment que nous sommes prêts à présenter
des décrets au Conseil d'État puisque c'est ce que
la loi prévoit pour agréer jusqu'à 25 territoires
supplémentaires j'ai dit à cette association qu'au
cours des dernières années le taux moyen de
sous-consommation de sous-consommation des
budgets était supérieur à 30 %. j'ai aussi dit à
cette association que nous pouvons nous engager
au cours de l'exercice 2024 à ce que 10 millions
d'euros soi apportés si nécessaire si la totalité
des crédits étit consommé à condition que les
projections de création d'emploi soient partagées
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui je rencontre
Monsieur Gallois le président du fond jeudi nous
aurons l'occasion de continuer à discuter mais
soyez à même d'entendre que lorsqu'on passe
entre 2023 et 2024 d'un peu moins de 45 millions
à 69 millions d'euros ce n'est pas une baisse de
budget et le gouvernement est au rendez-vous
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Danielle auonau pour le groupe la
France insoumiseci madame la Présidente lundi
dernier interrogé sur l'annonce du syndicat mixte
de gestion de l'eau et de l'assaainissement de
Guadeloupe qui déconseillait à la population de
consommer l'eau du robinet le ministre Vigier a
répondu voyez vous avez la chance d'avoir un
ministre qui est également biologiste qui va
vous donner les bons conseils et bien vous faites
couler l'eau vous la faites chauffer et après vous
la mettez au frigo mais bien sûr pourquoi les
Guadeloupéens et guadeloupéennes n'y avaient
pas pensé avant peut-être parce qu'il et elles
savent que le problème est structurel et ne se
réglera pas par des bons conseils de biologistes
tout ministre qu'il soit en Guadeloupe comme dans
plusieurs autres département d'idoutrem depuis
des années de nombreux dysfonctionnements dans
la gestion des usines de production d'eau potable
du réseau de distribution et de la gestion des
eaux usées entraîne une situation catastrophique
un/4 de la population de Guadeloupe n'a pas accès
tous les jours à l'eau du fait des coupures 31 %
de la population maoraaise n'a pas accès à l'eau
courante dans son logement entre 15 et 20 % de la
population de guyan n'a pas accès à l'eau alors
que cette région dispose de la troème réserve
d'eau du monde un habitant et une habitante
sur deux de la réunion ne peut pas pas boire de
l'eau du robinet car impropre à la consommation
mais tout cela vous le savez car depuis des
années habitants habitantes et élus de ces
territoire et de la nation tout entière alerte
sur cette situation le 2 juin 2023 un rapport
du Comité de l'ONU sur les droits de l'enfant a
même demandé à l'état français de garantir les
droits à l'eau et à l'assaainissement en outreem
et singulièrement en Guadeloupe à ce jour en plus
d'être condescendante les réponses de votre
gouvernement sont dramatiquement insuffisantes
heureusement la représentation nationale s
saisi du problème mardi dernier en commission
des finances la proposition de notre groupe
d'un plan d'urgence de 100 millions d'euros sur
le budget 2024 pour rendre effectif le droit
d'accès à l'eau dans les outrmers a été voté
madame la Première ministre conserverez-vous
ce financement ainsi que tous ceux adoptés
en commission en faveur des outremèes après le
Funest 43 que vous prévoyez sur la deème partie du
budget je vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
philippe Bet ministre en charge des outr mes merci
madame la Présidente m messieur les députés
madame auonau mépris madame bonau lorsque
la semaine dernière 24 he après l'ouragon Timi
Tami je suis allé sur place à la rencontre des
populations qui avait été pour certains dévasté
vous le savez et qui pour et qui pour d' ont
perdu leur outil de travail et il nécessitait
que l'on soit à côté d'eux et j'étais à côé
où est mépris où est mépris madame AUAU lorsque
Gérald le ministre de l'Intérieur a décidé
d'enclencher la reconnaissance de catastrophe
naturelle justement suite au passage de cette
agant ami à la Guadeloupe où il mépris madameonau
lorsque comme beaucoup de guadeloupéen et
guadeloupéenne j'ai constaté j'ai constaté
que l'eau était de couleur marron lorsqu'il
y a des grandes inondations et pourquoi madame
auonau et pourquoi madame pour raison simple
c'est que les les usines de traitement d'eau
ne marchent quasiment plus et Madame auonau
ù mépris puisque vous venez parler vous venez de
parler à l'instant des investissements financiers
ou il mépris lorsque nous signons la semaine
dernière pour 320 millions d'euros avec la
région je remercie le président haralus avec le
département je remercie le président Losbar de
manière à ce que l'on puisse enfin régler ses
problèmes où est méprise de ce gouvernement
pour l'au je repars ce soir à maotte je devais y
aller avec Géral armmanin qui doit rester sur le
territoire hexagonal parce que nous avons lancé un
plan de 400 millions d'euros donc nous sommes pas
dans le méb nous sommes dans la considération et
nous sommes dans la considération pour les femmes
et les hommes des territoires ultramarins
qui méritent enfin qui mérite enfin que ces
problèmes d'eau les prennent à bras le corps et
croyez-le bien madame obonau venez avec moi ce
soir et vous verrez que sur place nous jissons
et vous verrez que sur place nous avançons et
vous verrez que sur place et nous faisons des
progrès chaque jour je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame
merana Reed arbelo pour le groupe
GDR madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les ministres chers
collègues yaurana ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre des Armées le 21
janvier 2021 le traité sur l'interdiction
des armes nucléaires est entré en vigueur
il comporte des dispositions humanitaires ayant
tré à l'assistance aux victimes et à la remise
en état de l'environnement la France se refuse
à le ratifier or le 27 octobre 2023 Kiribati
et le Kazakhstan ont présenté une résolution
inédite aux nations- Unies celle-ci concerne
le lourd héritage des armes nucléaires mettant
l'accent à la fois sur les dommages physiques
et moraux aux victimes mais également sur la
remise en état de l'environnement dans les
états à touché par l'emploi ou la mise à l'esser
des armes nucléaires 171 États ont voté pour ce
texte les quatre puissances nucléaires ont voté
contre dans la France dès le dépôt du projet de
résolution des associations telles que Acan France
ont dénoncé l'attitude de rejet de la France perçu
comme un affran envers toutes les victimes de ces
essais y compris ses propres enfants le même jour
en réponse à une affaire concernant le stockage en
couche ologique profonde des déchets radioactifs
le Conseil constitutionnel a rendu une décision
inédite en estimant que le législateur lorsqu'il
adopte des mesures susceptibles de porter une
atteinte grave et durable à l'environnement doit
veiller à ce que les choix destinés à répondre
aux besoins du présent ne compromettent pas la
capacité des générations futures et des
autres peuples à satisfaire leurs propres
besoins les juges de la juridiction suprême
ont donc eux saisi les dangers du stockage
des déchets nucléaires et leurs effets nocifs sur
l'environnement et la santé humaine en Polynésie
les déchets nucléaires sont enfoui dans deux puits
d'un km de profondeur dans une zone géologiquement
instable car fragilisé par l'explosion de plus
de 140 essai nucléaires souterrain et menaçant de
s'effondrer à tout moment le ministère se félicite
du suivi géomécanique et radiologique de la tole
de mourourois avec le dispositif tels 2 merci ma
chère collègue merci parole est à Madame Patricia
mirales ministre en charge des anciens combattants
et de la mémoire madame la présidente madame la
députée Mariana Reid aberlot permettez-moi d'abord
d'excuser le ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
qui est occupé avec l'actualité internationale
complexe que vous connaissez peut-être je vais
commencer ma réponse en vous disant que nous
n'avons pas attendu un traité pour travailler
nous avons avec le le président de la République
ouvert les archives sur la Polynésie et donc il
y a 600 archives qui ont été ouvertes et qui
permettent aux historiens aux enseignants et
aux chercheurs de pouvoir se rendre compte de ce
qui a été fait avant sur les essais nucléaires
nous sommes évidemment héritiers de de cette
histoire et nous en faisons toute la lumière nous
en faisons toute la lumière peut-être vous dire
aussi que le ministère des armées est conscient de
ses responsabilités particulier sur ce sujet des
essais nucléaires en Polynésie il porte l'exigence
de la transparence vouue par le Président de la
République la surveillance des atols continue à
être réalisée selon un plan rigoureux et complet
le ministère des des armées a effectué une
rénovation du système de télésurveillance du site
que vous connaissez appelé tel site la dernière
publication de 2022 confirme que les objectifs
de surveillance ont été remplis tant en terme
d'alerte que du suivi de l'évolution géoécanique
les mouvements de la couronne corélienne sont
devenus très faibles et le détachement d'un
fragment important créant une vague est devenu
très improbable nous continuons naturellement la
surveillance les mesures effectuées permettent
de classer le niveau d'évolution au niveau zéro
de l'échelle des risques et à fagatova les les
campagnes d'observation périodique mené depuis
2001 confirme également la stabilité des atols
le prochain le mois prochain comme chaque année
une comm information rendra compte des résultats
de la surveillance je vous rappelle les résultats
de l'année dernière donc en 2022 du point de vue
radiologique on ne mesure dans l'eau les végétaux
et les poissons que des traces de réactivité à
très faible niveau identique à celle des années
précédentes merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Michel lozana pour le
groupe Renaissance merci madame la Présidente ma
questionade monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre
de la santé et de la prévention en ce 31 octobre
je tiens à saluer les associations et bénévoles
partout en France qui ont organisé des opérations
dans le cadre du mouvement octobre rose Ce ce
mouvement est né et vit grâce à leur engagement
je tiens également à vous remercier madame
la Présidente d'avoir illuminé la façade de
l'Assemblée nationale aux couleurs d'Octobre Rose
l'ensemble de des actions nous permet de véhiculer
deux messages essentiels d'abord apporter notre
soutien aux femmes et aux hommes touchés par un
cancer ainsi qu'à leurs proches aussi sensibiliser
la population à l'importance du dépistage détecter
tôt un cancer du sein se soigne dans 90 %
des cas la démarche est simple dè 25 ans il
est préconisé de procéder régulièrement à un
examen clinique ainsi qu'à des autopalpations
entre 50 à 74 ans tous les 2 ans un dépistage
gratuit recommandé pourtant en 2022 seulement
47 % des femmes éligibles à ce dépistage yy on
participé c'est insuffisant et en baisse depuis
la crise sanitaire c'est pourquoi je salue
monsieur le ministre votre volonté d'aller
vers les personnes les plus éloignées notamment
à travers le rendez-vous préventif à trois âges
clés votés par le Parlement en 2023 et adapté
au sein du PLFSS en 2024 cependant nous devons
aller plus loin la stratégie décennale de lutte
contre les cancers vise à réaliser 1 million de
dépistages supplémentaires entre 2021 et 2025
cela inclut aussi celui du cancer du sein qui
demeure la première cause de décès par cancer chez
les femmes aussi Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
nous exposer votre stratégie afin d'atteindre
les objectifs fixés par cette stratégie décennal
et d'améliorer le taux de participation au
dépistage du cancer du sein je vous remercie
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de la santé
et de la prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député euh
merci beaucoup de cette question et en effet la
santé des femmes était un des axes prioritaires de
cette partie 3 du du PLFSS que nous avons examiné
hier et même si elle est moins prestigieuse que la
façade du Palais Bourbon le celle du ministère la
santé est également habillé de rose pourquoi pour
dire la nécessité de la mobilisation absolue sur
le dépistage vous avez dit les chiffres 47 % des
femmes passent par le dépistage organisé 10 % à
peu près font d'elles-même ce mouvement vers le
dépistage nous devons aller plus loin parce que
nous avons reculé durant la crise sanitaire et le
cancer du sein c'est une femme sur 8 dans sa vie
qui va y être exposée et c'est aujourd'hui encore
12000 morts chaque année en France 12000 morts
dont une bonne partie s'ils étaient dépistés
plutôt serait évitable donc vous m'interrogez sur
la stratégie que nous mettons en œuvre la première
monsieur le député c'est de modifier notre manière
de mettre en place ce dépistage organisé les
centres régionaux de dépistage du cancer vont être
profondément remaniés avec des opérations d'allé
vert qui seront conduit par l'assurance maladie
et les ARS en prenant en prenant appui sur tout
ce que nous avons fait pendant la crise sanitaire
et par ailleurs les crcdc dans leur dimension
épidémiologique orienteront ces recherches nous
espérons bien atteindre 1 million effectivement
de dépistage de plus par an 2uxème élément une
mobilisation pour rénover le parc de mammographe
de 100 millions trè élément qui est très important
c'est les dotations en recherche et en innovation
notamment ce qu'on peut aujourd'hui voir en
terme d'interception du cancer c'est un progrès
immense et nous devons tous nous en saisir mais la
première étape c'est le dépistage vous avez raison
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Michel Guignot pour le rassemblement
national merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le ministre selon la
mission immigration asile et intégration
l'accueil et l'hébergement des migrants dans la
diversité de leur situation sont à la charge de
votre ministère c'est d'ailleurs principalement
à cette fin que vous avez versé en 2022 plus de
980 millions d'euros de subventions aux
associations ce chiffre qui a scandalisé
de nombreux Français et pourtant largement
sous-estimé en effet comme l'indique
en détail le jaune budgétaire sur l'effort
financier de l'État en faveur des associations
de très nombreuses subventions ont été versé
par la dial la Délégation interministérielle
pour l'hébergement et l'aide au logement pour
information les crédits de la dial de la dial
pardon qui depuis 2019 augmente chaque année de
10 % en moyenne sont affectés sur le budget du
ministère de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires dans le programme 170 7
ou plutôt devrais-je dire le potoros 177 le budget
discret pour l'immigration en effet sur la seule
année 2022 la dial a versé près d'un milliard
8 d'euros de subvention pour les demandeurs
d'asile c'est donc environ 60 % d'un budget créé
initialement pour aider les personnes sans abri
ou mal logé je rappelle 624 morts en 2022 depuis
2019 la dial a verser 6 milliards d'euros de
subvention pour l'accueil et l'hébergement des
demandeurs d'asile dont les 2 tiers d'ailleurs
ne devrai pas être dans notre pays la ma question
est donc simple monsieur le ministre une partie du
budget du ministère de la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoire finance-t-elle
discrètement par milliard une une immigration
dont 61 % des Français ne veulent pas et contre
laquelle vous affirmez vouloir lutter je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Sabrina Agresti roubage
ministre en charge de la citoyenneté de la
ville merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député Michel
Guignot écoutez vous nous interrogez sur les
financements accordés par le ministère en fait
de l'Intérieur et des outremèes aux associations
au titre de la politique d'immigration comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le rappeler en commission des
lois lors de l'examen des crédits de la mission
immigration asile et intégration l'état encadre
scrupuleusement les missions et les fonds qu'il
délègue aux associations qui compte pour près de
la moitié des crédits de la mission ce sont ces
associations qui assurent pour le compte de l'État
l'hébergement des demandeurs d'asile et à ce titre
accompagne ces personnes dans leur démarche où
accompagne les réfugés les réfugiés vers l'emploi
comme le programme d'accompagnement global pour
l'intégration des réfugiés le programme agir ces
associations sont effectivement des opérateurs de
l'État et participent activement à l'intégration
des étrangers en France Monsieur le Député ces
associations sont dans leur rôle en fournissant
un accompagnement administratif et juridique aux
étrangers qui souhaitent utiliser les voies de
recours juridictionnelles prévu dans le cadre
de la loi les associations ont également une
responsabilité notamment lorsqu'elle décide de
défendre publiquement un individu qui aurait fait
l'objet d'une décision de justice mais l'écriture
de la loi relève du Parlement monsieur le député
et c'est ce qu'il fera très prochainement en
examinant le projet de loi sur l'IMM imigration
qui porte une réforme de simplification très
importante pour simplifier les procédures et
réduire de 12 à 4 les catégories de recours le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres mèes a équé
évoqué aussi son souhait d'entamer un dialogue
sérieux et très concerté avec ses association je
souscris évidemment pleinement à cette démarche
je vous remercie il est encore merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre-Henri Dumont pour le complouet républicain
merci madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre les habitants de Calais du calisi sont
inquiets inquiets car une bombe industrielle et
environnementale se trouve en plein cœur de ville
à proximité immédiate des habitations et d'un
canal le 31 mai dernier l'usine chimique la CC
vaau so haut saint-exime propriété du groupe
axintis a été placé en liquidation judiciaire
ces 120 employés licenciés en portant avec eux la
connaissance du site depuis la direction d'acentis
refuse non seulement de se plier à la loi en
remettant le site de 24 hectares en état mais est
incapable de dire quel produit chimique se trouve
stocké dans des Fues en pleine air cet été déjà
deux incidents furent constaté sur le site sous la
forme d'émanation suspecte de fumée sur ce site se
trouve aujourd'hui 1900 tonnes de déchets dont
la plupart ne sont pas encore identifiés parmi
eux nous savons néanmoins que sont entreposés au
grand A parmi les produits les plus dangereux 15
tonnes d'amphétamine 350 kg de bromme et 69 tonnes
de canure si les amphétamines ont été évacués ces
dernières semaines le reste décomposé chimique
présent sur site font craindre une catastrophe
industrielle et environnementale un nouveau dazdf
ou briso en plein cœur de ma circonscription
madame la Première ministre nous ne pouvons pas
vivre dans la peur d'une telle catastrophe si
localement les représentants de l'État ont pris
le dossier à bras le corp il est urgent que votre
gouvernement agisse rapidement pour protéger les
habitants mes questions sont donc simples tout
d'abord quelle mesure comptez-vous prendre pour
identifier puis évacuer les 1900 tonnes de déchets
encore présents sur le site dont certains sont
extrêmement dangereux et dans quel délai ensuite
comment comptez-vous financer les évacuations
de déchets puis la remise en état du site alors
que le dirigeant de la maison mère de saintexie
maxintis n'a rempli ni ses obligations légales ni
ses obligations financières lors de la liquidation
de l'entreprise et que ce n'est pas au contribuaes
de mettre la main à la poche pour pallier
l'incurie du chef d'entreprise enfin allez-vous
réclamer les millions d'euros de subvention
publiques accordé au patron voyou d'acintis
que ce soit pour le site de Calais ou pour ces
autres sitres en France je vous remercie très bien
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député du mon merci pour votre
question merci aussi pour votre vigilance vous
avez rappelé les grandes lignes une liquidation
judiciaire au 31 mai d'un site ces vaiseaux
seuil haut et dès le début du mois de juin mes
services en l'espèce les inspecteur de l'ICPE ont
constaté que les obligations de mise en sécurité
n'avaient pas été rempli le préfet de manièreé
immédiate a pris des arrêtés sauf que comme la
société MRE s'est débrouillée pour ne plus être
joignable et pour ne pas avoir laissé les fonds
nécessaire pour permettre la mise en sécurité
j'ai demandé en coordination avec le préfet à
ce que l'adè au titre de l'urgence impérieuse
interviennent pour sécuriser et pour commencer
à évacuer l'ensemble de ces déchets dangereux
les amphétamines et les 15 tonnes c'est fait les
386 kg de brome les 69 tonnes de cianure ce sera
à compter de la mi-novembre que les opérations de
déstockage interviendront la particularité de ces
déchets nécessit des protocoles qui viennent
d'être validé et donc c'est à compter de la
mi-novembre ensuite il reste les 1900 tonnes de
déchets qui en terme de volume sont extrêmement
importants qui feront l'objet d'un conditionnement
et d'une sécurisation par la suite le financement
nous avons d'ors et déjà le préfet a fait le
nécessaire récupéré 805000 € dans le cadre des
garanties financières qui vont permettre d'être
directement fléché vers laad la suite c'est que
j'ai demandé au service de l'État à la fois en
région au niveau national d'activer l'article
l512 17 du code de l'environnement qui permet
d'aller rechercher comme vous le suggérez la
responsabilité de la maison mè accentis dans cette
histoire on ne peut pas engranger potentiellement
les résultats quand l'usine tourne le jour elle
a un souci s'arrêter en laissant les tonnes de
déchet avec la responsabilité de l'État pour être
capable d'y faire face il y a dans nos règles
code de l'environnement la possibilité d'aller
chercher la responsabilité de cette maison m vous
êtes entendu c'est l'action de l'État sur le plan
gouvernemental et local dans votre circonscription
je suis à votre disposition pour vous en donner
davantage d'explication merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane de
l'autreette pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi un incendie
s'est déclaré au CHU de Limoge faisant deux morts
et deux blessés grâce à la réactivité du service
sécurité des pompiers du 1087 des policiers et
de l'ensemble des personnels de l'hôpital le
pire a pu être évité et je tiens à renouveler
ici ma gratitude à chacun d'entre eux monsieur
le ministre je veux d'abord vous remercier pour
votre venue à limoge samedi l'instant était bien
évidemment au recueillement mais aujourd'hui je
veux vous alerter sur la situation dramatique
dans laquelle se trouvent les hôpitaux de haute
viienne car oui ce drame survient dans un contexte
plus que dégradé la semaine passée les urgences
du CHU ont accueilli jusqu'à 80 patients pour
seulement 15 boxes si l'engorgement est avant tout
structurel la fermeture répétée des urgences de
Saint-Junien à 30 minutes y contribue indéblement
autrement dit comment d'un hôpital en difficulté
on aboutit à deux hôpitaux en crise l'hôpital
de Saint-Junien parlons-en plusieurs semaines de
fermeture des urgences depuis juillet un service
de soins de suite et de réadaptation menacé de
fermeture et des personnels à bout de force je
pourrais aussi évoquer l'hôpital de saint-thirier
et bien d'autres établissements ruraux encore
chers collègues lequel d'entre nous ne connaît pas
une telle situation sur son territoire monsieur
le ministre notre hôpital et particulièrement
nos hôpitaux ruraux sont en urgence vitale
soignants et patients sont en souffrance
absolu les raisons vous les connaissez manque
de personnel tarification à l'acte gouvernance
inadapté et progression des déserts médicaux ni le
Ségure ni les mesures proposées au PLFSS 2024 ne
donnent d'espoir pour nos hôpitaux de proximité
monsieur le ministre nous attendons de vous des
décisions fortes à quand un moratoire sur la
fermeture des services ruraux de proximité à
quand la grande réforme de l'hôpital public dont
nous avons tant besoin bravo merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien
Rousseau ministre de la santé et de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député je souhaiterais tout
d'abord m'associer au mots que vous avez eu pour
les personnels du centre hospitalier université
de Limoge qui ont eu dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi une réaction exceptionnelle exceptionnel
de de courage d'abnégation et d'efficacité puisque
nous sommes passés tout près tout près d'un RAM
les personnels du service d'incendie de l'hôpital
sont montés sans protection resp atoire et en 15
minutes avec également des policiers qui étaient
arrivés sur place les personnels du 10 de la Haute
Vienne t les patients du bloc de chirurgie
viscérale ont été transférés nous avons la
douleur d'avoir de connaître un bilan lourd de
morts et vous étiez nous étions ensemble quand
nous avons rencontré les équipes qui étaient
déjà à nouveau au travail samedi mais et vous
avez raison de le dire l'héroïme auxquel on
renvoie souvent les soignants ça n'est pas
ce qu'il demande ce qu'il demande c'est de
pouvoir faire leur métier leur métier c'est
le soin au quotidien et Monsieur le Député je
crois que la version et la le tableau que vous
dressez est évidemment parti juste beaucoup
d'hôpitaux souffrent mais les mesures qui ont
été prises depuis plusieurs années commencent
à M à porter leurs fruits nous avons connu y
compris au centre hospitalier universitaire
de Limoge qui est l'hôpital pivot pour toute
l'exrégion Limousin une campagne de recrutement
plus importante la revalorisation annoncée par
la première ministre de 25 % du travail de nuit
est aussi un des éléments qui va permettre de de
fidéliser et le PLFSS porte une réforme notamment
pour sortir les hôpitaux qui ne tiendraient pas
par la seule tarification à l'acte de cette
situation je ne dis pas que tout est tout est
rose loin de là mais je pense que que nous nous
pouvons saisir ces chances et que les soignants
attendent aussi cette sérénité que nous pouvons
leur donner merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Florence lasser pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à la ministre des Sports
madame la ministre la Coupe du monde de rugby
s'est achevée samedi lors d'un match de finale
qui a vu l'équipe d'Afrique du Sud conserver
son titre si bien sûr nous ont tous souhaité
sur ces bancs voir nos bleus aller plus loin
nous ne pouvons qu'être fiers et nous féliciter
du formidable engouement qu'ils ont suscité
tout au long de ces semaines depuis le march
d'ouverture depuis sa nomination en tant
que pays haute en 2017 jusqu'à son point
final notre pays n'a pas manqué à sa réputation
tant pour l'esprit dans lequel il a accueilli
les centaines de milliers de supporters du monde
entier depuis la fraternisation d'avant pendant
d'après match jusqu'à la diffusion de notre
magnifique hymne de l'Aviron Bayonnais que
pour la gestion logistique de cet événement nos
infrastructure de transport aérien ferroviaire de
transport en commun tout comme l'hébergement ont
démontré leur capacité à absorber un flux aussi
important nos forces de sécurité
ont permis à la compétition de se
dérouler dans les meilleures conditions je
crois que nous pvons les féliciter et les
enercier pays sont d'ors et déjà positives
aussi bien en terme économique qu'en terme
d'image et cela est de bon augure pour le futur
madame la ministre avec les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de l'été prochain d'autres échéances
d'une ampleur encore plus grande s'annonce aussi
quel bilan dressez-vous de cet événement et quels
sont les points qui vous semblent devoir retenir
notre attention pour que l'organisation de ces
jeux soit à l'image de cette coupe du monde de
rugby je vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame madame Amélie ouea Castera ministre
des Sports des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
madame la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député la sererre par de là
le déchirement en effet de l'élimination du 15
de France contre les futurs vainqueurs oui cet
événement aura été un formidable succès avec
d'abord des records battus beaucoup de records
battus de fréquentation dans les stades avec 2,4
millions de spectateurs dans les fan zones avec
1,6 million de spectateurs et même la meilleure
audience télé de l'année en France pour ce match
France Afrique du Sud tout programme confondu on
a accueilli 600000 visiteurs du monde entier avec
une organisation fluide efficace et parfaitement
coordonnée entre toutes les parties prenantes
qui a permis passer les premiers rages du début
de délivrer une expérience à la hauteur
de l'événement cette coupe du monde elle
a été aussi organisée avec des standards
particulièrement élevés en matière sociale
écologique d'inclusion avec un impact positif
sur le plan économique pour nos territoires
et un héritage déjà effectif sur la pratique
sportive et sur les métiers du sport alors oui
cet événement est aussi riche d'enseignement pour
la suite beaucoup d'enseignements positifs d'abord
en matière de sécurité le dispositif piloté par
gerérald haranin a fait la preuve de sa robustesse
en dépit d'un contexte particulièrement exigeant
en matière de transport nous avons su adapter
sous le pilotage de Clément baun des renforts
de capacité d'effectifs avec les opérateurs de
transport en pleine coordination avec ceci que je
salue en matière d'engagement populaire on a su
avec les collectivités mettre en place un bon
modèle de fan zone dont on va s'inspirer pour
les jeux au titre des améliorations en plus du
travail qui se poursuit sur l'accessibilité de
nos infrastructures la gestion opérationnel des
flux de spectateurs et le point sur lequel nous
avons le plus progressé en cours d'événement
pour mieux guider les spectateurs étrangers
pour affiner l'information voyageur optimiser le
positionnement des volontaires sur les parcours
dans leur orientation cette agilité collective
elle s'est aiguisée au fil des matchs elle sera
un acquis pour les jeux avec cette coupe du monde
on a fait rayonner notre pays on va continuer à
faire émerger une nouvelle référence d'événements
sportifs plus sobre plus responsable et plus
solidaire je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la ministre la parole est à Monsieur Vincent
Rolland pour le group les républicain merci madame
la présidente madame la Première ministre l'hiver
approchant permettez-moi attirer votre attention
sur un sujet du quotidien pour nos concitoyens
qui habitent en zone de montagne celui de la
sécurité routière et des déplacements sur nos
routes enneigées en décembre 2016 le législateur
pensait y avoir répandu dans l'acte 2 de la
loi montagne il s'agissait de l'obligation pour
tout véhicule se déplaçant depuis vert entre des
communes de montagn d'être équipé de pneu neige
ou quatre saisons ou à minima de posséder des
chaînes ou chaussettes dans le coffre permettant
d'affronter les conditions climatique avec un
niveau de sécurité et de motricité renforcé
rapporteur pour l'évaluation de l'application
de cette loi en 2020 avec Marie- Noël baptistel
nous vous avions pourtant informé de cette non
apppplication il nous avait d'ailleurs été répondu
que ce serait imminent or 3 ans plus tard à la
veille de son entrée en vigueur demain le 1er
novembre le décret d'application n'est toujours
pas connu je ne vous cache pas qu'il règne une
certaine confusion autour de cette obligation
madame la Première ministre pouvez-vous nous
éclairer sur la suite donnée à ce dossier
et clarifier la position des assureurs en cas
d'accident impliquant des véhicules ne possédant
pas les équipements requis pour u sur nos routes
de montagne l'économie du tourisme est essentielle
en zone de montagne mais encore faut-il respectter
le quotidien de celles et ceux qui vivent et qui
travaillent chaque jour je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député Roland en l'absence de mon ministre
délégé au transport Clément bun j'ai la joie de
vous répondre sur un sujet que je sais que vous
maîtrisez particulièrement à la fois contenu de
la circonscription que vous représentez mais de ce
que vous avez évoqué par le passé 34 départements
à comptter de demain sont concernés par des
arrêtés préfectoraux pour au moins une de leurs
communes et pour l'obligation du 1er novembre au
31 mars je ne reprends pas tout ce que vous avez
indiqué d'être où équipé ou d'avoir ce qu'il faut
dans le coffre et cetera à l'instar d'ailleurs de
18 pays européens sur les 27 que compte l'Union
européenne l'objectif premier avant d'être de la
répression c'est bien de la sécurité et tous ceux
qui ont voté ce texte tous ceux qui l'ont porté
le savent c'est la première cause d'accident qui
provoque les blocages auquel vous faites référence
compte tenu ensuite des conséquences économiques
qu'elles peuvent avoir mais dans un premier temps
tout simplement des risques pour les femmes et les
hommes qui circulent dans ces véhicules d'être
eux-mêmes blessés à la minute où nous parlons
il n'y a pas de décret créant la sanction dans
le cadre du code de la route pour le non respect
de cette obligation la visée pédagogique
a conduit à ce que jusqu'à maintenant nous
procédions à des contrôles et dans l'hiver qui
commence demain d'un point de vue administratif
ce que je peux vous annoncer dans l'application
des règles hivernales qui commence à compter du
1er novembre nous nous tenons prêt à dégainer
ce décret si les contrôles montrent que nous
n'avons pas des taux d'équipement suffisants
de la part des automobiliste il a été souhaité
qu'on laisse de années pleines pour que les
gens s'habituent à la réglementation et ce
décret pourrait être pris dans l'hiver qui arrive
les services du ministère délégué au transport et
les miens se tiennent à votre disposition merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre Monsieur Roland
oui monsieur le ministre à partir de quel
pourcentage peut-on considérer que nos
concitoyens respectent la loi ou à défaut prendre
un décret si jamais ça n'était pas le cas quel est
le pourcentage que vous estimez merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe Benz pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Économie Bruno Lemire
monsieur le ministre sur le grave problème de
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat qui frappe très
durement les Français depuis trop longtemps on
ne vous lâchera pas on ne vous lâchera pas car
les Français vous hurlent leurs désarrois et
leurs inquiétude mais vous ne les écoutez pas
les députés du rassemblement national sont là
pour vous le rappeler chaque jour si besoin les
Français souffrent ils sont malheureusement de
plus en plus nombreux dans un contexte de crise
économique sévère et de crise inflationniste
inédite les Français veulent des actions concrètes
des mesures fortes exceptionnelles pour certaines
durable pour les autres en tout cas efficace
et surtout au plus vite pour se nourrir pour
se soigner pour se chauffer pour se déplacer bref
pour vivre une vie digne en France au 21e siècle
la peur de la fin du mois est une préoccupation
majeure pour des millions de Français et elle
est parfaitement légitime depuis des mois nous
réclamons des mesures simples alimentation énergie
soins transport voilà les priorités sur lesquelles
Marine Le Pen a fait de nombreuses propositions
concrètes aux effets immédiats lors de la
présidentielle pour le moment vous exercez encore
le pouvoir faut-il que les Français attendent 2027
pour que nous mettions nous enfin en place les
mesures de bon sens pour améliorer leur quotidien
et rendre à nos concitoyens la vie plus simple et
une vie plus douce par avance je vous en prie
ne nous répondez pas encore comme d'habitude
que tout va bien que vous avez raison que vous
faites tout bien que vous êtes les meilleurs les
Français méritent mieux que de la communication
gouvernementale il ne vous demande qu'une seule
chose agissez avec rapidité et efficacité
je vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
à Madame Olivia grégoard ministre en charge des
petites et moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les Députés
monsieur Christophe Bens vous m'autoriserez à
vous parapraser parce que nous non plus nous
ne lâcherons pas nous ne lâcherons pas ce que
nous avons enclenché depuis 6 ans au service
des Français et que vous ne voulez pas entendre
nous ne lâcherons pas tour de l'emploi dans notre
pays avec plus d'un million et demi d'emplois
créer depuis 2017 nous ne lâcherons pas la
réindustrialisation de ce pays avec 300 usines je
sais ça vous fatigue monsieur Tangui mais c'est
la vérité 300 usines qui ont réouvert leurs portes
depuis 2017 pas moins de 90000 emplois industriels
à nouveau créés nous ne lâcherons pas le partage
de la valeur que les députés de la majorité ont
porté avec force je sais que ça vous paraît peu
c'est quasiment 5 milliards c'est 4 millions et
demi de salariés qui ont vu 800 € de plus cette
année nous ne lâcherons pas la croissance qui
au 3è trimestre dans un contexte très difficile
est encore au rendez-vous nous ne lâcherons pas
ce que nous faisons pour accompagner les Français
du bouclier tarifaire à l'indemnité pour ceux qui
ont des difficultés à se déplacer en voiture avec
le prix des carburants nous ne lâcherons pas notre
combat avec Bruno lumer contre l'inflation
alimentaire dont vous avez oublié de dire
depuis ce matin qu'elle est passé sous la barre
des 8% et que l'inflation glissante est à 4 %
nous ne lâcherons pas l'investissement des
entreprises 1,5 % d'investissement en plus
je sais ça ne fait pas vos affaires mais c'est
la réalité du tableau économique de la France
nous ne lâcherons pas non plus la consommation
des ménages qui tient qui résiste ça vous ennuie
mais elle tient plus 07 % encore ça n'est pas la
question êre les meilleurs n'est pas la question
d'avoir raison c'est la question de regarder le
tableau économique de la France tel qu'il est et
ce qui ne fait pas vos affaires c'est que nous
n'entrenons pas le désespoir mais bel et bien
l'optimisme contrairement à d'autres merci merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la parole est à Madame
Farida pour la France insoumise merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre le 27 juin
dernier les quartiers populaires se révoltaient
après la mort un entre du jeune Naël tué par un
policier cet événement s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'une multiplication des violences pour refus
d'obtempéré favorisé par l'adoption de la loi
case neu depuis 2017 les tirs mortels sur les
véhicules ont été multipliés par 5 en 2022 13
personnes ont été tuées dès lors comme comme
en 2005 le soulèvement des quartiers populaire
est une révolte politique pourtant jeudi à la
à la Sorbonne vousnon vous annonciez en grande
pompe des réponses 100 % répressives sanction
pour les parents création de centes d'encadrement
par les militaires nouveau pouvoir pour la police
municipale en minimisant en misant sur tout le
sécuritaire pardon en plutôt que l'abrogation de
la loi cas ne vous refusez vous refusez d'entendre
les revendications exprimées plutôt que de
pénaliser les parents et de réprimer les enfants
renforcer au services publics trois d'entre eux
sont toujours menacés d'effondrement l'éducation
alors il est anormal que dans ma circonscription
des enfants de moins de 16 ans soient chaque année
sans affectation et donc livrés à eux-mêmes la
santé à l'heure où nos hôpitaux tombent en ruine
et où nos quartiers deviennent peu à peu des
déserts médicaux la sécurité enfin alors que le
lien de confiance entre la police et la population
est désormais rompu madame la Première ministre
quand allez-vous élaborer avec les acteurs de
terrain et les élus de proximité unact social
ambitieux pour nos quartiers populaires merci
beaucoup ma cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verrand porte-parole du gouvernement et
en charge du renouveau démocratique merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
madame la députée Farida Amrani il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire sur le constat que
vous faites et que je ne partage pas notamment
sur l'origine politique des émeutes urbaines qu'
a connu la France vous le comparez à 2000 2005 moi
je ne suis pas d'accord je considère que s'il y a
eu un drame initial la motivation d'ailleurs les
enquêtes de police et et de justice l'ont montré
dans moins de 10 % des cas le la situation du
jeune Naël a été évoquée par les hmetiers je
pense qu'il faut pas tout mélanger et je crois que
dans les mouvements qu'on connu un certain nombre
de villes et de quartiers populaires de nos villes
françaises faut pas y voir forcément de la révolte
politique en tout cas c'est pas mon cas néanmoins
madame la députée après avoir dans un premier
temps montré qu'on était capable de rétablir
l'ordre d'arrêter les fauteurs de trouble et de
punir et bien c'est posé la question de savoir ce
que nous faisions dans la durée pour les quartiers
populaires d'abord pour éviter qu'il y ait des
nouvelles am urbaine et puis ensuite pour arriver
dans le cadre de la politique qu'on appelle le
CIV qui est le communité interministériel des
villes à savoir comment est-ce qu'on continue
de développer une politique à destination des
quers des quartiers prioritaires quand vous
dites que tout est 100 % répressif je je veux
bien qu'on soit dans l'émicycle qu'on fasse des
vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux on on doit être
capable de se parler quand même madame la députée
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a de répressif dans le fait
madame la députée qu'on ouvre au collège de 8h
à 18h dans les quartiers prioritaires qu'est-ce
que c'est de tout répressif quand la Première
ministre annonce une politique de testing pour
lutter contre les discriminations à l'embauche ou
à l'accès au prêt immobilier qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de 100 % répressif lorsqu'on met en place un plan
entrepreneuriat quartier 2030 pour aider justement
les jeunes qui on du talent dans nos quartiers à
arriver à investir et entreprendre je veux dire il
faut qu'on sorte des slogans en permanence parce
que les gens qui vous écoutent ont l'impression
qu'on s'occupe pas d'eux alors qu'en réalité on
s'occupe d'eux et c'est des choses sur lesquelles
on peut se retrouver de la même manière madame
la députée jeis élu d'une d'une circonscription
que vous connaissez puisquelle est gérée par
la France insoumise Grenoble vous voulez qu'on
parle du bilan grenoblois depuis la franceç
insoumise la France insoumise est au pouvoir
je vois madame la députée qui est là il y a plus
de rénovation urbaine il y a plus de programme
en rue on laisse les pauvres s'entasser dans les
quartiers on met même plus d'eau sur les places
des marchés des quartier pop donc regardez
ce que vous faites là où vous gagnez ensuite
donnez-ous des son merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Emmanuel allez-y ma cher transparente mais quand
même j'existe donc monsieur le ministre vraiment
franchement ce qu'attendent nos jeunes et il y
a du talent dans nos quartiers et moi ce que je
vois c'est pas du tout ce que vous êtes en train
de me décrire donc du coup monsieur le ministre
je vous invite vraiment à venir dans mon dans
les quartiers populaires de ma circonscription
chich venez donnez-nous rendez-vous et allons-y
ensemble je vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Emmanuel pour le group naissance merci
madame la Présidente cette question s'adresse à
Monsieur monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald armanin monsieur le ministre la Coupe
du monde de rugby vient de s'achever par une
finale de titan entre la Nouvelle-Zélande et
l'Afrique du Sud si beaucoup de Français comme moi
auraient aimé voir notre 15 nationales aller plus
loin dans la compétition l'engoument du public
s'est confirmé avec plus de 3,4 millions de
spectateurs dans H stades différents sur tout le
territoire un peu plus si on ajoute les fan zones
nous pouvons vous féliciter Monsieur le Ministre
ainsi que tous ceux qui ont contribué à ce très
beau succès tant au niveau de l'organisation que
de la sécurité malheureusement les incidents de
dimanche qui ont conduit à l'annulation du
match de foot omol démontre que rien n'est
acquis ma question concerne la sécurité des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris 2024 fort
du succès construit avec le rugby pouvez-vous nous
faire un point monsieur le ministre sur les moyens
qui seront mis en œuvre pour la sécurité des JO à
venir merci je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald daranin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des outre maire merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député merci pour les policiers les
gendarmes les agents militaires de sentinelle pour
les agents de sécurité privée également qui ont
garantti la ministre des sport l'a dit une très
belle coupe du monde de rugby si joset je voulais
dire qu'il y a les bleus sur le terrain et nous
avons supporté notre équipe et puis a les Bleus
en dehors du terrain qui ont gagné la Coupe du
Monde de la sécurité puisque n pu nous avons pu
accueillir des centaines de milliers de personnes
2 millions de visiteurs partout sur le territoire
national avec des opérations zéro délinquence 4900
opérations avec plus de 800 interpellations malgré
tout avec 500 alertes à la bombe qui évidemment on
pour essayer de désorganiser la Coupe du monde et
en même temps le pape à Marseille en même temps le
roi et la reine d'Angleterre en France et en même
temps les risques terroristes que nous connaissons
donc merci pour les policiers les gendarmes les
préfets et les militaires de de sentinelle c'est
effectivement une réussite que nous pouvons en
effet évoqué comme étant une réussite d'abord
du système de sécurité français pour les Jeux
Olympiques et pour les Jeux paralympiques il y
a évidemment encore à travailler d'abord sur la
sécurité privée même si là nous avons eu que 3 %
de défaillant agents de sécurité privée donc ils
ont donc été au rendez-vous que ce soit dans les
stades ou en dehors des stades il y a un travail
évidemment à faire contre les cybers atttaques
vous le savez 4 milliards de cyberattaques
pendant les Jeux de Tokyo alors qu'il y avait le
covid il faut donc y travailler sous l'autorité
de la première ministre les drones et notamment
les drones malveillants plus d'une vingtaine de
drones malveillants ont été arrêtés neutralisés
grâce à la loi que vous avez voté d'ailleurs
monsieur le député pendant la couponde de rugby
ils vont se multiplier évidemment pendant les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et puis la lutte
contre la délinquence o vous le savez il y a une
mobilisation sans précédent des policiers des
gendarmes entre juin débarquement de Normandie
jusqu'à septembre c'est-à-dire jeux paralympiqu
où les policiers gendarmes font un effort sans
précédent de congés reporté de présence et
de présence MIF grâce à la loi que vous avez
voté puisque nous avons 8000 policiers gendarmes
supplémentaires pour garantir ces Jeux Olympiques
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre mon cher
collègue oui je voulais juste ajouter à vos
mots monsieur le ministre mes remerciements aussi
aux forces de police que je visite régulièrement
force de police de gendarmerie et de pompiers
dans ma circonscription et je sais qu'il se
prépare merci merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame Martine Froger pour le groupe
lot merci madame la Présidente ma question
ma question s'adresse à la ministre des
collectivités territoriales et de la ruralité
madame la ministre le gouvernement a entrepris
de réformer et de fusionner les différents
zonages dans un dispositif appelé maintenant
France ruralité revitalisation qui doit entrer
en en application en juillet 2024 le niveau
dispositif qui modifie un certain nombre de
critères va impacter de nombreuses communes
partout en France le chiffre parle de lui-même
on passerait de 17000 communes bénéficiaires à
14000 soit une exclusion de 20 % des communes
actuellement bénéficiaires chez moi en Ariège
les élus et les entreprises installées sur ces
zones sont inquiets comment rassurer les communes
qui vont sortir du dispositif au regard des
critères de revenu médian par habit et la hausse
démographique dans un contexte d'aggravation
de la fracture territoriale c'est là un très
mauvais message adressé aux départements les plus
ruraux ce dispositif et son zonage constitue un
alément d'attractivité indéniable sur lequel
s'appui largement les communes du département de
laarège les élus sont donc fortement attachés
à cet outil de soutien au développement des
territoires ruraux conçu comme un dispositif
symbole d'équité territoriale au-delà de cette
réforme ponctuelle il devient urgent de réfléchir
collectivement pour définir les axentiel d'une
politique d'aménagement du territoire efficace au
service du bien commun alors madame la ministre
mes questions sont simples comment comptez-vous
rassurer les communes sortantes du dispositif
actuel de ZRR et quelle mesure d'accompagnement
entendez-vous prendre pour éviter à pour éviter à
ces territoires d'être fragilisés davantage encore
par ce désengagement de l'État plus largement ne
pourrait-on pas réintégrer certaines communes qui
doivent sortir du dispositif en prenant en compte
la particularité géographique des territoires et
notamment les handicaps naturels je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma cher collègue la parole
est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre
de la transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la députée Froger
Dominique fort qui a porté cette ce projet France
ruralité étant retenu en audition j'ai la
joie de vous répondre cet après-midi d'abord
partons du début ce dispositif de ZRR il était
censé s'éteindre le 31 décembre 2021 il vient
d'être prolongé deux fois de suite dans le cadre
des lois de finances initiales et la première
ministre Elisabeth borne a pris l'année dernière
en novembre dernier un engagement solennel devant
l'Association des maires de France en disant que
nous allions conserver un zonage spécifique et
plus qu'un zonage créer même un zonage spécifique
parce qu'on avait jusqu'à maintenant un zoneage
unique mais avec l'idée qu'on avait parfois besoin
d'aller plus loin que les zones de revitalisation
rurale avec une sorte de dispositif ZRR plus
ou FRR plus pour reprendre le nouveau cycle la
disposition que vous évoquez c'est l'article 7
initial du projet de loi de finance 2024 avant
qu'il n'arrive dans cette assemblée avant qu'il
ne soit débattu ici puis au Sénat et nous savons
les attentes d'une partie des parlementaires sur
le sujet qu'est-ce qu'il y a à la minute où nous
parlons six départements qui sont intégralement
zonés je sais le Cantal l'Indre la Creuse la
hauteemarne la Meuse et la Nièvre je sais que la
lozer l' rège ou hasard considère qu'il devrait
faire partie de du même groupe nous avons
aujourd'hui retenu un critère de déprise
démographique supérieur à 4 % sur une période
de 10 ans à ça s'ajoute des communes avec le
maintien d'une maille intercommunale et avec une
nouveauté qui est la possibilité pour les préfets
d'aller rattraper des communes à une maille
communale si leur richesse ou leur densité lié
à l'intercommunalité dans laquelle elle elle se
situe ne bénéficie pas du dispositif nous faisons
confiance au dialogue avec les parlementaire ici
pour regarder si ce dispositif est parfaitement
adapté ou s'il doit être légèrement recalibré
merci pour votre question merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre la parole est à Monsieur William
Martinet pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Logement monsieur
le ministre gouverner c'est d'abord loger son
peuple cette citation de l'abbis Pierre a plus
d'un demi-siècle et pourtant elle raisonne
avec force aujourd'hui elle rappelle votre
échec les locataires sont assommés par les
hausses de loyers que vous avez décidé 3,5 %
l'année dernière 3,5 % cette année depuis que
le Président Macron a été réélu il faut payer
l'équivalent d'un 13e mois de loyer c'est une
honte les augmentations de charges sont astronomi
jusqu'à 200 ou 300 % votre bouclier tarifaire ne
protège pas les gens il protège les super profits
des multinationales de l'énergie c'est une honte
des milliers d'étudiants dorment au camping à
l'auberge de jeunesse où doivent renoncer à leurs
études votre refus de construire des logements
CROUS les a empêché de choisir leur vie c'est
une honte les habitants du littoral voient leur
logement confisqués par Airbnb et les résidences
secondair les enfants du pays restent à la rue
pendant que les multipropriétaires dictent leur
loi c'est une honte tout cela monsieur le ministre
c'est votre bilan la macronie a mené une politique
d'austérité qui a tout détruit c'est une saignée
historique l'effort public pour le logement
n'a jamais été aussi bas depuis les années 70
en 2017 vous nous promettiez un choc de l'offre
mais monsieur le ministre le seul choc qui a eu
lieu c'est le choc de la misère en cette rentrée
2800 enfants dorment à la rue deux fois plus que
l'année dernière mais vous ne comptez rien faire
pas même ouvrir les 10000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence demandé par les associations pour sortir
de la crise du logement il faut d'abord sortir de
la logique libérale sortir de la financiarisation
il y a une solution monsieur le ministre le retour
de l'État un état qui investit pour construire des
logements sociaux dont nous avons besoin un état
qui finance la rénovation des logements pour tenir
nos engagements écologiques un état qui régule les
prix des loyers et du foncier pour garantir
le logement abordable gouverner c'est d'abord
loger son peuple monsieur le ministre si vous
ne vous en sentez pas capable laissez-nous faire
bravo je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Patrice vergrit ministre en charge du
logement madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Martinet l'accord que nous avons passé avec le
mouvement HLM à Nant témoigne de l'engagement du
gouvernement en direction du logement social je
vous en rappelle quelques chiffres 1,2 milliards
pour accompagner la rénovation énergétiqu des
logements locatifs sociaux dans les 3 ans qui
viennent et 8 milliards de prêts bonifiés de
la Caisse des Dépôts équivalent à 650 millions
de charges et si le mouvement Hlm a bien signé cet
accord c'est parce qu'il est substantiel justement
pour pouvoir tenir deux engagements majeurs la
rénovation énergétique des logements sociaux
qui est indispensable pour le confort et le boir
d'achat des locataires et également la production
de logements sociaux vous évoquez les loyers les
loyers effectivement ont été plafonnés à 3,5% au
lieu de 6 au lieu de 6 % sans le plafonnement et
les APL ont été alignés sur ce même 3,5 % ce qui
permet effectivement au locatair qui bénéficient
d'APL de pouvoir effacer cette hausse mais je
voudrais aller plus loin avec vous monsieur le
député aujourd'hui c'est intéressant de mesurer
les taux d'effort de nos concitoyens dans le
logement social comparativement au logement privé
le premier décile en particulier de nos
concitoyens c'est-à-dire les plus pauvres
dans le logement locatif social le taux d'effort
est de 29 % il est de 52 % pour le même décile
dans le parc privé et oui c'est pour ça monsieur
le député qu'il est absolument indispensable de
garder le logement locatif social de le
protéger comme nous le faisons mais aussi
de mettre l'accent pour accompagner les logements
locatifs dans le parc privé également m'interroger
également sur l'hébergement du aucun gouvernement
n'a fait comme celui-ci le plan logement d'abord
reconnu par toutes les associations un passage
de 93000 place à 203000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence jamais aucun gouvernement n'a fait cet
engagement merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre pont
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse au ministre de
la santé et de la prévention monsieur le ministre
selon l'Agence nationale de la sécurité
du médicament plus plus de 3700 ruptures
ou risque de rupture de médicaments sont recensés
sur le sol français en 2022 contre moins de 200
en 2012 cette année les pathologies hivernales
ne sont pas encore arrivées et il y a déjà une
pénurie d'antibiotique comme laamoxicyine dans
plusieurs régions et plus particulièrement dans
les haut de France et dans le sud-est les causes
de ces pénuries sont multiple et conjoncturel
avec la guerre en Ukraine et une explosion
de la consommation chinoise de médicaments
en cause également une extrême concentration
de la production en effet certains médicaments
sont fabriqués uniquement par une seule entreprise
rendant très fragile la la chaîne de distribution
cette pénurie dernière pénurie le vaccin contre la
bruciolite des bébés est déjà en rupture de stock
la commande effective de 200000 doses ne peut
pouvoir semblet-il répondre à la forte demande
actuelle le gouverne ement vient d'annoncer
récemment une relocalisation des entreprises
et son intention de rendre obligatoire la vente
de certains antibiotiques à l'unité pour réduire
le gaspillage une commission d'enquête du Sénat
de juillet 2023 esquise des pistes pour sortir
de cette situation comme la mise en place d'une
production européenne des médicaments essentiels
pour répondre à cette pénurie urgente de
médicaments je vous serai reconnaissant
monsieur le ministre de bien vouloir nous faire
connaître les mesures que vous comptez prendre
rapidement je vous remercie merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien
Rousseau ministre de la santé et de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député oui nous avons connu
l'an dernier une extrêmement forte pénurie de
médicaments et nous connaissons à nouveau cette
année des tensions sur certains produits pour
répondre très directement à votre question
j'ai mandaté l'Agence nationale de sécurité
du médicament qui suit 450 des médicaments
prioritaires dont la moxiciline et qui vous l'avez
sans doute vu s'est vu renforcer ses pouvoirs de
police sanitaire notamment pour essayer quand il
y a du blocage dans le circuit de distribution
d'assurer que les les médicaments arrivent bien
dans toutes les pharmacies alors que au niveau
global nous avons des stocks et donc le sujet
c'est bien de suivre à chaque étape l'industriel
le grossiste répartiteur le pharmacien jusqu'au
patient pour savoir où se situent ces blocages
mais vous avez raison aussi Monsieur le le député
pont de le souligner tous les pays d'Europe
connaissent ces difficultés ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on reste les bras croisés nous avons
proposé notamment sur la moxicyine en échange
d'une garantie par les industriels qui sont en
effet très concentrés de de volume de livraison
à la France une augmentation des prix qui n'a pas
d'impact sur le prix payé par le consommateur par
le patient et donc nous avons aujourd'hui des
stocks qui sur le plan global sont satisfaisants
et nous avons des régions vous les avez cité
où l'accès est difficile je réunirai la semaine
prochaine tous les industriels les grossistes
répartiteurs et les représentants des pharmacies
pour comprendre pour et mettre en œuvre tous les
moyens nécessaires pour assurer ce déblocage et
par ailleurs deux remarques complémentaires
nous avons ciblé 25 médicaments essentiels
le président de la République s'est engagé dans
une visite à ardèch a engagé leur relocalisation
et je m'assure auprès des industriels qu'ils
tiendront leurs engagements c'est un point
essentiel et sur le bfortus croyz cro bien
tous les jours nous essayons notamment avec
la première ministre de compléter cette livraison
à la France de 200000 qui est déjà la plus grosse
livraison pour un pays d'Europe merci monsieur
le député merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame ménage pour le rassemblement
national merciés présidente ma question s'adresse
à Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé Rousseau il
n'y a pas un sujet où ce gouvernement ne fasse
l'autruche niant en parlement son rôle de contrôle
interdisant au français un débat équitable en
détournant systématiquement la disposition 493
de notre Constitution ce gouvernement nous le
savons maintenant a en horreur le dialogue et
la sincérité le 13 juin dernier j'aiinrogais ce
ministère qui est le vôtre quant à la politique
inavouée de fermeture des maternités vos équipes
m'informer alors ne pas suivre les préconisations
de l'Académie de médecine ne pas avoir je cite
de politique volontariste de fermeture des
établissements de santé depuis 2000 le taux de
fécondité des Français est inchangé pourtant
ce sont aujourd'hui 111 maternités que vous
voulez fermer comme le soulligne le syndicat des
gynécologues qui pointe du doigt cette catastrophe
dont vous niz la responsabilité entre autres la
maternité de pon déjà close et la prochaine à
suivre sera celle dancen vous ne pouvez pas nier
conduire cette politique de fermeture au prétexte
du risque d'un service mal calibré risque que
vous transposé et accentué par la saturation des
CHU engorgé par ces mamans qui doivent faire près
d'une heure de route pour mettre au monde leurs
enfant votre argument idiot n'est que paradoxe
et contradiction avec le réel comme d'habitude
alors je vous le demande monsieur le ministre
comptez-vous continuer cette transformation des
services publics en organismes prestataires
de servicees où seuls vos bureaucrates sont
en compétition pour plaire à votre régime où
ils promuvent leur carrière par le même dénis
les mêmes trahisons et la même feinte permanente
du bon sens par la caricature du raisonnement si
c'est le cas alors on ne baigne plus seulement
dans le dans le cynisme mais on pâuge dans
l'imbécilité merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de la santé
et de la prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la députée merci
de cettera question vraiment tout en nuance euh
la maternité de Peron dont vous me parlez euh a
réalisé cette année jusqu'à la suspension de son
activité faute d'un anesthésiste réanimateur qui
permettent d'assurer la continuité des soins elle
a réalisé jusqu'au début octobre 96 accouchements
96 accouchements je vais vous dire quelque chose
madame la députée c'est peut-être techno imbécile
ou un des adjectifs que vous avez employé
la médecine c'est un art dans lequel il faut
savoir faire les gestes les gestes qui sauvent il
faut savoir les faire parce qu'on les rencontre
plusieurs fois dans une journée plusieurs fois
dans une semaine 96 accouchement jamais nous
n'avons cherché à fermer cette maternité il se
trouve que ça signifie quand même un accouchement
tous les 3 jours ça signifie que une éclampsie je
voudrais être sûr que le gynécologue soit capable
d'intervenir assez vite et donc entre la promesse
que vous faites vaguement d'égalité et le fait de
savoir que une parturiante elle sera prise en
charge et que son bébé et elle-même ne mourront
pas en couche il y a une différence entre nous en
effet vous dans votre monde alleer à Saint-Quentin
ou à Amien c'est un déchirement je comprends
que ça puisse être un déchirement mais moi mon
déchirement c'est si sur vos arguments politiciens
la variable d'ajustement c'est la santé et la
sécurité des soins ça je ne m'y résoudrai jamais
je ne me résoudrai jamais à fire service pour des
questions de finan le 111 que vous évoquez je
ne vois pas à quoi vous faites référence mais
je ne me résoudrai jamais à laisser ouvert un
service dans lequel je ne conseillerai à aucun
de vos collègues ou à quiconque de se rendre pour
faire pour faire accoucher sa famille donc oui il
y a un principe ser sécurité santé sécurité des
soins c'est ça le la promesse républicaine avant
tout madame la députée je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre madame la députée com prend bien votre
seule réponse au manque de personnel soignant
c'est la fermeture des maternités des hôpitaux
alors j'ai qu'une seule chose à dire vivement
2027 que Marine Le Pen soit élue merci je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur thry bonoî pour
le groupe au raison merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Agriculture je voudrais
aborder avec vous la mise en œuvre de la politique
agricole commune dans le délai 2023-2027 et
plus particulièrement la question des mesures
Agri environnementales et climatiqu jusqu'à 2022
c'était les régions qui qui étaient les autorités
de gestion de ces fonds européens et combiné à des
crédits publics d'état des régions de l'Agence de
l'eau ça permettait aux agriculteurs qui s'engage
dans des pratiques vertueuses notamment dans le
domaine de l'élevage particulier ulrement en
Bretagne d'engager leur profession vers la
transition écologique pour ce qui est du programme
2023227 l'état approvisionné environ 90 millions
d'euros la direction régionale de l'agriculture
de l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt en Bretagne
prévoit 150 millions il y a donc rien que pour la
région Bretagne un delta de 60 millions région de
France estime cette ce manque pour le territoire
national à peu près à 250 300 millions les mesures
agro-environnemental et climatique c'est un
contrat entre les agriculteurs et la puissance
publique pour embarquer l'agriculture vers la
transition écologique on ne peut donc pas se
manquer se louper lorsque c'était les régions qui
pilotaient ce projet ce dispositif ça fonctionnait
bien monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture
depuis longtemps on vous alerte depuis septembre
en commission des affaires économiques on en a
beaucoup débattu vous avez reçu des courriers de
parlementaires il faut à tout prix que vous vous
saisissiez de cette question et c'est sous votre
autorité que l'ensemble des partenaires doivent
se mobiliser pour accorder ces financements il n'y
aurait rien de pire que de démontrer que lorsque
c'est l'État qui gère les crédits européens c'est
un échec ce serait aussi une façon de faire
détester la politique agricole commune alors
que pour la agriculture particuli BR merci la
parole est à Monsieur Marc PHENO ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté alimentaire
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député Benoît
merci de votre question qui va me permettre de
compléter la réponse que j'ai fait tout à l'heure
à votre collègue mollac et saluer la mobilisation
d'un certain nombre de vos collègues enfin la
totalité je crois des collègues de Bretagne
sur cette question des Mikes comme on dit de ce
pilier important de la PAC je rappelle ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure d'abord la politique agricole
commune dans l'ensemble de ces politiques que nous
avons posé pour la période 2023- 20027 il y a la
volonté de faciliter d'accélérer de renforcer le
volet des transitions c'est l'écorégime c'est
la conversion en agriculture biologique et les
ma font partie du dispositif deuxème élément il
a quelque chose que pardon de le dire comme ça
je suis élu régional je suis un territorial vous
le savez monsieur le député le sujet n'est pas
de savoir qui gère le sujet c'est que sur la
précédente programmation nous avions 2500 55
millions de crédits qui étaient prévus sur les ma
que nous avons provisionné 260 millions d'euros
mais je peux pas me retrouver et j'en appelle un
peu à la responsabilité dans une situation on me
disent c'est pas 260 c'est 500 qu'il faut parce
que ce n'est pas une politique de guichet la
politique des Mac et donc on a besoin de trouver
un chemin qui permette entre les exigence qui
avaient été posé le cadre budgétaire que tout
le monde connaissait qui était de 250 millions
d'euros de regarder ce qu'on peut faire pour
essayer de répondre vous avez raison et de ne pas
décourager les agriculteurs qui veulent s'engager
sur ces politiques j'ai évoqué deux pistes tout à
l' à l'heure la région Bretagne a beaucoup de
mobiliser les Maek et c'est une bonne chose
parce qu'effectivement ça permet de faire évoluer
les systèmes sur le carbone sur la biodiversité
sur l'eau et donc on sait que c'est important et
donc on sera au rendez-vous comme on l'a été sur
l'ensemble des politiques il y a deux pistes la
première c'est de bien vérifier que conformément
aux engagements qui ont été pris les agences de
l'eau mobilisent les crédits supplémentaires qui
étaient prévus au niveau national c'est-à-dire
70 million d'euros par an deuxième élément de
regarder aussi dans la politique agricole ce que
sont les relicat mais Monsieur Benoît pardon de
vous dire que les relicat ne les connaî qu'en fin
d'année donc j'essaie de faire des prévisions nous
sommes mobilisés vous le savez mais je peux pas
inventer des dispositifs tant que je ne regarde
pas ce qui est dans la PAC possible et capable
d'être mobilisé puis pardonnez-moi de le dire
l'État s'était mobilisé autour des régions je
suis sûr que les régions se mobiliseront autour
de ce sujet là la région Bretagne en particulier
pour trouver des solutions budgétaires faut pas
toujours tout demander à l'État merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole est à
madame la Présidente Chatelin pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la présidente Madame
la la première ministre en 2014 Robert baninter
écrivait 70 ans se sont écoulés depuis la nuit de
l'occupation les crimes nazis et de leur complices
de Vichy le temps de l'histoire a succédé au
temps de la mémoire les derniers témoins vont
disparaître à leur tour et l'antisémitisme est
toujours vivant oui l'antisémitisme est toujours
vivant la recrudescence des actes antisémites
en France nous le rappelle cruellement 819 actes
antisémites ont été recensés ces trois dernières
semaines c'est deux fois plus d'actes antisémite
que sur la totalité de l'année 2022 à Paris dans
les hautes scènes et en scène Saint-Denis ce
sont des dizaines et des dizaines d'étoiles
de David qui ont été taguées sur les murs des
immeubles à villeurbane c'est une synagogue
qu'on a menacé d'incendier à Paris une mésousa
fixée à la porte d'un appartement a été brûlée
ces actes intolérables s'attaquent à notre pacte
républicain ces actes antisémites décomplexés et
nausés à bond contreviennent à l'article 1er de
notre Constitution la France assure l'égalité
devant la loi de tous les citoyens sans
distinction d'origine de race ou de religion
elle respecte toutes les croyan madame la Première
ministre le 10 octobre dernier vous avez déclaré
dans dans cet hémicycle ne toléer aucun acte
aucun propos antisémiste et je voulais vous
dire dans cette lutte vous avez le plein et
entien soutien des écologistes nous avons
nous allons devoir traiter la racine du mal ce qui
caractérise l'antisémitisme c'est la permanence de
la stigmatisation et nous avons blessé baissé les
bras aujourd'hui les actes que nous connaissons
sont les conséquences d'une longue banalisation de
la parole antisémite et raciste le négationnisme
de Jean-Marie Le Pen le rémisionisme d'Éric
Zemmour l'antisémitisme complotiste de Dieu
donné et de Soral madame la Première ministre je
conclurai avec les mots et la question de Robert
banater il en va de l'antisémitisme comme du
racisme ce sont des poisons de la République
à une certaine dose elle en meurt alors madame la
Première ministre comment éradiquer cette violence
et dissiper l'ignorance merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la Présidente
cyiel châelin je vais le redire très clairement
rien ne justifie l'antisémitisme rien n'excuse
l'antisémitisme jamais et je sais que ces propos
madame la Présidente vous les partagez et je peux
vous assurer qu'avec mon gouvernement nous sommes
déterminés à mener une lutte implacable contre
l'antisémisme contre l'antisémitisme et vous
l'avez rappelé madame la présidente châelin depuis
les attaques terroristes du 7 octobre sur Israël
nos concitoyens Juifs vivent dans l'angoisse
depuis le 7 octobre comme je le disais plus de
850 faits antisémites ont été recensé et près
de 6000 signalements ont été faits en ligne nous
ne laisserons rien passer madame la Présidente
ni la haine sur la voie publique ni la
haine sur les réseaux sociaux ni celle
qui se dissimule derrière l'antisionisme c'est
pourquoi des consignes de vigilance ont dès le
7 octobre été passés au préfets et aux forces
de l'ordre c'est aussi pourquoi les préfets
ont dans certains cas pris des interdictions
de manifestation pour prévenir tout dérapage
ou trouble à l'ordre public la situation au
proches Orient ne doit être le prétexte à
aucune tentative de récupération aucune volonté
d' les haines ou de souffler sur les braises
l'antisémitisme est un poison nous savons tous
où il peut mener alors ensemble nous devons le
combattre avec la plus grande force et la plus
grande détermination et je sais pouvoir compter
sur vous madame la Présidente comme je sais
pouvoir compter sur l'ensemble des députés
qui partagent les valeurs républicaines plus
encore face aux tension internationale nous
avons chacun un rôle à jouer pour apaiser et faire
nation je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre la séance des questions
au Gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue